deep below the Pacific Ocean lies a
tectonic
monster you know how we told you not to
panic well that's all
off Panic run for your
life the world's biggest tsunami
machine it's dangers hidden from
view until
now
imagine if we could empty the
oceans letting the water drain away to
reveal the secrets of the
seaflow now we
can using the latest underwater scanning
technology piercing the Deep oceans and
turning accurate data into 3D
images this time is the world's next
Mega earthquake Brewing off the coast of
Seattle we can have the big one right
now as we speak why has the discovery of
an underwater volcano just 44 mil from
Tokyo got seismic experts so worried and
what do scientists caught up in an
undersea earthquake learn about the
dangers facing New Zealand the front of
it would have a huge amount of energy
the scale is just immense drain the
oceans reveal
the secrets of the deadly
Pacific the Pacific Ocean the planet's
largest and
deepest 500 million people live around
its
Coast
but deep beneath the waves lurks a
terrifying monster that threatens all of
them the planet's largest and most
dangerous seismic
Zone the ring of
fire 90% of all earthquakes strike
here and when they do the consequences
are
devastating
[Music]
March 11th
2011 tku Northeastern
Japan a magnitude 9 earthquake violently
shakes the
region the Quake causes buildings to
collapse and people to Flee for their
[Music]
lives but that's not the end of the
destruction a defining characteristic of
the ring of fire is that the biggest
earthquakes here Shake not just the land
but the seabed as
well generating huge surges of
water
deadly
[Music]
tsunamis
in Japan almost 16,000 people are
killed and geologists are certain it
will happen
again somewhere around the Pacific ring
of
fire but when and
where pulling the plug on the Pacific
Ocean reveals a glimpse of one of its
most terrifying Secrets just off the
west coast of
America not the infamous San Andreas
Fault in
California but something close to the
teeming cities of Portland Seattle and
Vancouver something far more
menacing it's known that it's an active
structure it could happen now and that's
that's truly the source of
[Music]
fear this region of North America is
known as
Cascadia one of the most beautiful and
peaceful in North
America it's also home to 10 million
people they feel safe here and why
wouldn't
they in all recorded history there's
been no trace of any natural disasters
in the
region but on the 18th of May
1980 Everything
Changes there is no question at all that
the volcanic activity has begun Mount St
Helens 50 m from
Portland huge eruptions blast a 1300t
crater in the summit of a volcano long
thought to be dormant
it is the biggest eruption uh ever
recorded of Mount St Helen so far I
think it does not look good for people
in that area now it's the worst volcano
disaster in US history claiming 57
lives scientists are now forced to ask a
tough question is it is it failed to
look at tsunamis does the eruption of
the supposedly inactive Mount St Helens
mean the 10 million inhabitants of
Cascadia are now sitting on a seismic
time bomb that just started ticking to
find out scientists launch an urgent
investigation on land and deep under the
sea off the coast of Cascadia the latest
scanning technology reveals something
extraordinary and
terrifying based upon their exact data
for the first time we can pull the plug
on the Pacific Ocean to reveal their
shocking
Discovery as the water drains away a
vast world no human has ever seen before
is laid
bare for mile after mile across its
heart the Pacific ocean floor is a vast
flat featureless
plane until
suddenly the landscape
changes here just 150 mil from the great
cities of the Pacific
Northwest a dramatic transformation
takes place revealing a fractured broken
sea
Flor brooding
menacing one of the best analogies I can
think of is looking at the the front end
of a car that's been in a head-on
collision dented and corroded and
corrugated into this complex
mess the scale of this geological fender
bender is truly
epic colossal Cliffs almost twice the
height of the Grand Canyon
some deep enough to hide six empire
state buildings stacked on top of each
other all of it stretching 700 miles
along the Cascadian
Coastline this Titanic rupture in the
Earth's crust is what geologists call a
subduction
zone
at the core of our planet is a boiling
cauldron of molten iron surrounded by a
thick mantle of
rock that outer crust is divided into
huge tectonic plates that are constantly
in
motion when they Collide they thrust
mountains upwards and carve deep
trenches into the ocean floor as one
plate drives the other back inside the
earth if the plates lock together
tremendous pressure begins to
build only in subduction zones where the
plates are compressing together and
there's this lock between the plates
that those are the only fault zones that
have the potential to create magnitude
9.0 and higher
events but that's not all subduction
zone zones because they are underwater
can generate not just earthquakes but
huge
tsunamis written history suggests that
cascadia's subduction zone has been
inactive for
centuries but does written history go
back far
enough is this monster really as sleepy
as it
seems
scientists scour the landscape around
Cascadia in search of
answers and in the banks of coastal
Rivers like this they find an alarming
pattern it's very much like a a
chocolate cake you slice a chocolate
cake and there's a layer of brown
frosting and then down below there's
another layer of brown frosting and the
Washington coast looks very much like
that but there's nothing sweet about
these layers of Pete and sand each of
these buried soil layers on the
Washington coast reflected times when
when the coast had been jerked downwards
by the occurrence of an
earthquake in the layers of Pete David
Yamaguchi and geologist Brian Atwater
unearth evidence of seismic Devastation
stretching back over thousands of
years Quakes that scarred the entire
Coastline of Cascadia the question now
is when was the last one and how big was
it the kapalis river Washington
State scientist David Yamaguchi is on a
quest he and his fellow scientists
already suspect that the 10 million
inhabit habitants of Cascadia are living
on a seismic Time
Bomb but when did it last go off and how
big was it when it
did 3 mil Inland he comes across a
haunting
sight
this is what's left of a once mighty
forest of red cedar and Spruce
trees thousands of petrified corpses
scattered over hundreds of miles along
cascadia's coast and the Mystery here is
what killed the trees and when did they
die sampling dozens of the
trees Yamaguchi analyzes their AG rings
and what he finds is a new mystery the
trees were fine and healthy in
1699 then the following summer the trees
that that would normally have produced
another annual ring were nearly all
dead what happened to kill an entire
forest in one
instant another scientist thinks the
answer could lie
deep in the geological car crash of the
Cascadia subduction zone just 100 miles
away Chris Goldfinger is an underwater
earthquake
detective seeking evidence in core
samples taken from deep under the seaf
Flor studying the layers of sediment
reveals when and where earthquakes
struck in the past and and how powerful
they
were sediment settles to the seafloor
but it got there somehow from some storm
an earthquake even a volcanic eruption
will leave a deposit on the seaf Flor
and so it's just a a very precise
three-dimensional tape recorder just
recording every single thing that
happens well this is a core sample from
the from the seaf Flor off of
Cascadia and it's about 2,000 years
worth of sediment in the middle of the
sample dating to roughly 300 years ago
Goldfinger finds the classic signs of a
large earthquake well in fact the shells
like this turn out to be shallow water
fossils but this is a deep water core so
these things were carried down from
shallow water to Deep Water what this
points to is a fairly dramatic kind of
event that dramatic event was an
earthquake that triggered a vast
underwater
Landslide and it all happened around the
same time that yamaguchi's trees
died next he Compares core samples of
the same date Taken along the 700 miles
of the Cascadia subduction
zone core after core reveals the same
Disturbed layer all occurring at the
exact same
time this is evidence of No Ordinary
earthquake but a
monster Cascadia through the study of
past earthquakes has shown that it's
capable of generating earthquakes that
run the full length roughly 1,000
km in 1700 the Cascadia subduction zone
generated a cataclysmic Quake along its
entire length with a magnitude that
Goldfinger and other scientists
calculate as level
eight but that's not
all this was more than just an
earthquake Japan has a long history of
earthquakes and
tsunamis with written evidence going
back 1,400
years among these historical records in
accounts written by Sam and Merchants
researchers uncover reports of a 16t
tsunami that arrives from far out in the
Pacific swamping the eastern coast it
destroys houses and causes villagers to
flee to Higher
Ground the date of these
reports
1,700 they proposed that our earthquake
was magnitude 9 a magnitude 8 was not
big enough to produce a wave that's that
wide in addition based on the arrival
times of the waves in Japan the
earthquake must have happened here on
January 26th 1700 at 9:00 at night yes
local
time the Cascadia Mega Quake was so
powerful that it generated a tunami that
hit Japan
4,500 mil away
using the combined insights of experts
from both sides of the Pacific and the
extraordinary drained landscape of the
subduction
zone it's now possible to visualize the
Titanic events of January
1700 and its deadly trail of
Destruction the entire subduction zone
shakes very hard
the ground motion is big and it's over a
big area so it's going to shake a lot of
sediment
loose there are going to be hundreds of
landslides they're going to all come
tumbling down the slope and leave a
deposit the Quake also triggers a huge
tsunami which smashes into the coast of
Cascadia flooding the land with
seawater including the red cedar forest
and everything else in its
path although there is no written
history of the 1700 earthquake and
tsunami in Cascadia native peoples of
this region do hold haunting memories of
these terrible
events the First Nation peoples had oral
histories about the great battle of
Thunderbird and
whale it had a lot of shaking of the
ground washing away of
villages the great Thunderbird finally
carried the whale to its nest there were
a shaking jumping up and trembling of
the earth beneath and a rolling up of
the Great Waters it's once these stories
came to life the Native Americans
essentially said why didn't you just ask
us we knew all about
that the story had a moral and the moral
was don't build your village too close
to the
beach but evidently no one was
listening today 10 million people live
along the coast of Cascadia and in the
cities of Seattle Portland and
Vancouver and the question is How likely
is it that the monster will Roar again
it's not at all like a clock but the
average time between the earthquakes is
on the order of 400
years if the Cascadia subduction zone
repeats its 400-year cycle then its next
megaquake could be imminent we know the
strain is building and we know one day
it's going to be released and that could
happen any day so what will happen
when the monster wakes me a subduction
zone earthquake energy is stretched out
not 10 seconds or 20 seconds more like 3
minutes the shaking is not incredibly
violent but it lasts for a long time and
it's a very long rolling motion for tall
buildings that's not good
[Music]
news with buildings collapsing and
infrastructures shattered it will be
hard for the population to escape from
the coastal
area the worst place to be
trapped you know that if you get a giant
earthquake you better assume you're
about to get a giant
tsunami the tectonic Plate's sudden
release of pressure forces a massive
swell in the ocean
above so the wave height initially might
only be a couple of meters but might be
200 km long and it heads out at the deep
water wave speed which is very fast so
it's jetliner speed 5 or 600
mph everything we've seen in Japan we
can expect basically the exact same
thing in Cascadia
tunami 30 m of water rushing in at 10 m
a second kind of
velocities they just scour everything
off the off the surface of the
Earth within 20 minutes the tsunami will
approach the coast of Cascadia when that
wave starts feeling bottom like all
other waves do it gets compressed from
200 km down to kilm or two it's like an
enormous tide happening very
quickly a Cascadia megaquake is
predicted to be North America's Worst
ever natural
disaster the fatalities could be fairly
large we're looking at a few tens of
thousands of people at least on our
Coastline we know the strain is building
that's quite harrowing to know that we
could have the big one right now as we
speak but Cascadia is not the only
populated region in the ring of fire
danger
zone as the Waters of the Pacific
continue to drain away they reveal
another Sleeping Giant near the east
coast of New Zealand where scientists
discover traces of an epic seismic event
that reshaped the Southern hemosphere
and ask when will it happen
again the islands of New Zealand lie
directly on the ring of
fire small earthquakes shake the ground
here every
[Music]
week in 2011 the country's second
largest city Christ Church is devastated
by a magnitude 6.3 Quake I can confirm
that we have been deaths killing
185 people
[Music]
100 miles from Christ Church is the town
of kaiura
[Music]
Cur welcome aboard thank you a peaceful
holiday Resort that's popular with
nature lovers looking out you see
they're just out in front of us it's
deep nutrient-rich Waters entice whales
close to the shore
this is the
Beau is awesome to
see while these leviathans are kora's
star
attraction geologists now come here for
a very different
reason New Zealand's geologists
constantly monitor the threat posed by
The Faults and fissures that run under
the islands trying to discover where the
next big Quake might
strike ground surveys can help but
investigating under the waves has always
been a challenge until now because the
latest multiple beam sonar technology is
opening up a hidden world it's multiple
beams of um Sound Energy being released
from the instrument on the vessel and we
time how long it takes for that beam to
come back
we do what we call mowing the grass and
we're just collecting this continuous
image of what the shape of the seabed
is and the shape of the seabed near
kaiura is not what they
expected as the data comes in it slowly
reveals something
astonishing and potentially
lethal pulling the plug on the Pacific
Ocean exposes the remarkable
sight just a half mile from the town of
kakura as the water drains away it
reveals the plunging walls of a vast
undersea
[Music]
Chasm the kakora
canyon the carota canyon it comes within
a really short distance of the Coastline
out here less than a
kilometer and from there it drops down
at 30 40° down to about 600 M water
depths then it carries on down to about
2,000 M water
depths stretching for over 37 miles the
canyon forms part of one of the deepest
sea channels in the
world the walls nose dive over 6,000
ft
the depth of the Grand
Canyon geologist Wonder at the immense
geological forces involved to create
such a huge
Canyon but also ask themselves does it
pose a threat to those living on the
nearby
Coast geologists know that land slides
triggered by earthquakes in underwater
Canyons can generate lethal
tsunamis could the kakura canyon do the
same on board the research ship tangaroa
they investigate let's try it
again using perspect tubes they gather
evidence from the sedimentary layers on
the Canyon's
floor looking for signs of seismic
activity in the
past
Yep this is score two but then just as
they're studying history they get the
chance to make
some midnight November 14th
2016 we are undergoing a fairly dense um
earthquake at the moment
so please just get to somewhere where
you are safely under some protection I
can honestly say I doubt that I'll be
able to stay in the chair for much
longer the 7.8 magnitude Quake rips
apart the Earth creating giant crevices
and billions of dollars of
damage geologist joshu mountjoy has
never seen anything like
it the key thing was that it just
covered such a large geographic area and
it was right on our Coastline the Quake
rattles the ground for 2 minutes causing
thousands of landslides across 3,800
square
miles just north of kikura is the
biggest 800 million cubic feet has
shaken to the ground exposing a vir
Cliff face almost a mile wide grass and
Tusk we're standing on was connected to
that grass and Tusk up there and then
the whole block slid right down to bring
it down to where it is now so this has
um happened during the earthquake we
call that co-seismic and it is actually
a fault line running through here that
runs right down to the coastline the
shaking is so severe that it thrusts the
foreshore of kakura upwards by 3 ft in
just 1 second
we look out here we can see a whole lot
of seaweed that's stranded above the
tideline before the earthquake that
would have been down below the sea
level but joshu mountjoy isn't only
interested in how the earthquake tears
apart the land as soon as the earthquake
begins he wants to know the effect it's
having deep under the ocean in the newly
scanned kikura
Canyon Mount Joy makes contact with the
research ship tangaroa which is mapping
the very far end of the canyon we
requested that they divert their energy
to focus on doing some earthquake
response that response is to immediately
gather core samples from the floor of
the canyon before the dust has settled
so we we already had an unprecedented
opportunity to assess well what what is
the aftermath of a major earthqu if the
crew responds in time they can achieve a
world first recording the impact of an
earthquake in a deep sea Canyon as it
happens within minutes of the earthquake
the crew retrieves precious core samples
from the seaf
Flor they collected the sedimentary
deposit that had only just happened so
they were pouring it while it was
probably still seing out of the ocean
and what marine geologist Alan orpin
discovers is intriguing some kind ofy
I'm not quite sure of it what we found
was a very soupy fluidized mud that was
uh lying on the
seabed as we moved South what we found
was compelling evidence core after core
for uh a thickness of material that had
spilled down through the channel the
more samples they take the clearer the
picture becomes the shaking of the Quake
has created a secondary and truly
spectacular undersea upheaval no one's
has ever been able to observe one of
these huge landscape scale Canyon
flushing events to show exactly what
effect it had on the canyon
[Music]
itself using the data gathered by the
crew of tangaroa and the remarkable
drained Seascape the impact of a large
earthquake on a gigantic underwater
canyon can now be visualized for the
very first time
the seabed shutters ominously as huge
tectonic forces power through the
Earth's
crust this dislodges a top layer of
sediment becoming a gigantic Canyon
flushing
Landslide Rock and sediment tumble down
down the Steep
walls 850 million tons of debris Roars
through the canyon gouging 160 ft out of
the
floor there really like a powder snow
Avalanche the front of it would have a
huge amount of energy moving at about 70
km an hour and maybe 400 m
High
it's spreading tens of kilometers across
the ocean
floor it's just going to take over
everything that's down there the
landslide travels with such velocity it
carves a path across the sea floor for
an astonishing
miles a landslide of this ferocity has
the potential to generate a tsunami that
could devastate
kakura when a landslide creates a
tsunami you need a large chunk of
material to slide down slope and what
happens is it's coupled to the water
above it and actually pulls it down with
it and then as that water rebounds then
you create your
wave this time kaiura is lucky no large
objects fall off the Canyon Rim next
time the town may not be so
fortunate and the dramatic events of
2016 draw the geologists attention to an
even bigger tsunami threat
nearby by continuing to drain the ocean
off the Northeast Coast of New Zealand
we can see the reason for their
fear lurking just north of the canyon
and frighteningly close to the New
Zealand capital of Wellington
the hikurangi subduction
zone
2,174 mil of seismic
trouble geologists recently learned that
stress has been building at its southern
end for hundreds of
years and they believe that the 2016
earthquake has ratcheted the pressure up
even further
[Music]
understanding what's happening here has
become an international
priority a 100 ocean floor seismic
measuring devices and support scientists
recently arrived from
Japan they're here to Monitor and record
the mounting stresses in the hope of
discovering the true danger of hikurangi
[Music]
geologists delve deep into the
subduction Zone's tectonic
past and their results are
astounding it hasn't fractured recently
but deep in its past It produced
something bigger than anyone had
imagined Now using the geologist data
it's possible to reconstruct for the
first time a tectonic event that
reshaped a
hemisphere the ruatoria
Avalanche just 200 miles from what today
is New Zealand's bustling Capital
Wellington the epicenter of one of the
biggest seismic events in the history of
the
earth 170,000 years ago the Australian
plate is bearing down on its Pacific
neighbor grinding down everything in its
path even a towering volcanic cone six
times the volume of Mount Fuji becomes
collateral
damage the resulting seismic shock
triggers an underwater Landslide on a
scale rarely seen moving a swath of
broken rock the equivalent of 3/4 the
size of the Grand Canyon
so the Rory avalanch is the second
biggest submarine landslide in the world
it's absolutely enormous 3,000 cubic km
and if you can try and visualize a cubic
kilometer that's a kilm high by a kilm
long by a kilm wide 3,000 of
them nobody knows when the hiang
subduction zone will fracture
again but when it does geologists
estimate the tsunami wave from the mega
Quake will take only 7 minutes to reach
New Zealand's Capital City Wellington
and it's half a million
residents and such a huge tsunami
wouldn't only impact New
Zealand there would be an oceanwide
alert as the waves fan out into the
Pacific the last time a tsunami on this
scale hit the southern Arc of the Ring
of Fire was December 26th
2004 devastating 14
countries and killing
230,000
people a terrible reminder Remer of the
power of the deadly
Pacific continuing to drain away the
Pacific Ocean reveals a very different
kind of seismic threat 5,000 m
away right next to one of the most
densely populated cities on the planet
just 44 mil from bustling Tokyo a
mysterious underwater feature has
scientists on the edge of their
seats the island nation of Japan suffers
from its position on the ring of
fire the country accounts for about 20%
of the world's earthquakes of magnitude
six or
greater its biggest city Tokio has been
hit by nine Mega earthquakes in the past
95 years
but just 44 miles off the city's
Shoreline geologists have recently
discovered a new and very different
tectonic
Troublemaker the first discovery is made
by scientist Ken
Tani he's heading out to test his new
underwater remotely operated vehicle or
ROV in the waters just off the island of
Oshima south of Tokyo bay until now the
waters here have been considered safe
passage for one of the busiest shipping
lanes into the port of Tokyo with 400
vessels passing through here every day
but that is about to
[Music]
change 44 miles from Tokyo bay Ken Tani
prepares an underwater survey using an
ROV passing over a rocky Mound on the
sea floor he discovers something
extraordinary a seismic Beast that has
Lain hidden for hundreds of thousands of
years using Kent Tani's own data
draining away the Pacific Ocean reveals
what is lurking below the
waves as the water
recedes it exposes a large flat
Plateau near its Center what looks like
an ordinary hole in the
seafloor but on closer inspection the
frightening truth emerges it's the vent
of an under sea
volcano thousands of years ago it very
likely had a towering cone but erosion
and wave action has worn it down which
is why no one discovered it
before but is it as dormant as it
appears Ken wastes no time in exploring
the crater so that's the sea surface
testing the water temperature around the
outlet with a submarine thermometer and
what he finds surprises everyone we
found this very active high temperature
hydral B which suggests even more that
it's ban volcanically active we first
got very excited but at the same time we
I started to get concern about the
potential hazards if erops in the near
future
the smoldering undersea volcano is named
umad dasi 44 mil south of
Tokyo placing at risk the lives of
thousands of mariners in the shipping
lanes
above in
1952 an underwater volcano like Umar
adashi erupts 260 m south of
Tokyo superheated magma reacts with
water to produce what's called a fro
magmatic explosion an underwater steam
bomb a nearby ship is engulfed in the
explosion killing all 31 on board the
big problem with the submarine volcano
it can erupt
anytime and even from a small eruption
if the boats were going above it it can
cause sever
Maritime safety
issue a stirring volcanic giant is not
just a danger to
shipping a major eruption could send
tsunami waves racing towards Tokyo
population 38 million even from a very
small eruption it can cause uh severe
impact Ken decides he needs to keep Umar
ad under
surveillance nothing happens for 5 years
then when he returns to gather fresh
samples Umar adashi has another
unpleasant surprise for
him returning to the drained ocean floor
Reveals His next shocking
Discovery in addition to the crater five
more volcanic
cones that's five more more possible
outlets for the
volcano only one is currently active but
all could become so and if the volcano
keeps growing Umar adashi could become
an even greater Threat by breaking the
surface and spewing toxic Ash into the
[Music]
sky active volcanoes can do this
astonishingly
quickly it took nishinoshima Japan's
latest volcanic island just 2 years to
grow from a Flatt topped underwater
Summit to this tectonic
monster measuring one square mile and
443 ft
high but nishinoshima is nearly 600 M
from Tokyo Umar adashi is only
44 once out of the water any major
eruption of Umar adashi could shower
Tokyo in choking volcanic
ash despite the dangers Kent Tani and
his team continue to monitor Umar
adashi any increase in the volcano's
activity could signal impending disaster
for the thousands living on nearby
islands and threaten the safety of
millions in nearby
Tokyo draining the ring of fire has
revealed hidden geological
wonders and
Terrors exposing new evidence of this
immense power of plate
tectonics and its ability to
create and
destroy
Hitler's darkest
secrets and most terrifying
weapons lost below the
waves until
now imagine if we could empty the
oceans letting the water drain away to
reveal the secrets of the
seafloor now we
can using the latest underwater scanning
technology piercing the Deep oceans and
turning accurate data into 3D
images this time was Australia's most
prized warship destroyed by a Nazi
Secret
weapon what made this killer yubo
invisible and how close did Hitler come
to building an atomic
[Music]
bomb
Hitler's ambition was
Global as the Waters of Northern Europe
drain away they reveal evidence of the
Nazis most terrifying weapon of
all
Norway Lake
tin how did a secret operation here
destroy a Nazi nuclear dream
at the bottom there's this Nazi secret
no one can be sure about what's down
there during World War II Nazi
scientists begin the race to harness
Atomic
power Hitler's dream uh was to develop
this bomb that could really devastate
and Destroy
London
turning the war in the blink of a second
that was his
dream but the Nazis need a crucial
ingredient to make an atomic
bomb it's called heavy
water heavy water was a vital component
of the attempt of the Germans to get
their nuclear reactor to work
it's chemically hydrogen but it's
heavier it's twice the
weight the world's largest producer of
heavy water is near Lake tin in
Norway theor power
plant once the world's largest
hydroelectric power
station it's this energy that powers the
creation of the precious heavy
water April 9th
1940 Germany invades
Norway the Nazis were eager to get
control of the heavy water at the weor
plant due to the reason that they wanted
to use it as a cooling Aid in their
nuclear uh
reactor in 1942 at the peak of the
production here at VOR they produced as
much as 1,000 kilos of heavy
water over a ton is a big step towards
building Hitler's first nuclear
reactor it looked as if Germany might
well get a nuclear bomb quickly and the
Allies were obviously very concerned
about
that Churchill wanted the heavy water
plant to be
destroyed theor power plant becomes a
priority Target for Allied Air Raids and
sabotage damage like this eventually
forces the Nazis to safeguard their
stockpile of the precious
commodity February 20th
1944 the Nazis plan to move almost a
Year's output of heavy water by train
from
theor the carriages will cross Lake tin
by
ferry from here the cargo will travel to
Germany to the site of a nuclear
reactor soldiers load around 40 barrels
onto Railway
carriages the hydro Ferry
departs but it never reaches its
destination at 10:45 in the morning it's
sinks the cargo tumbles into the
water 27 people are rescued 26 go down
with the fery mostly innocent
civilians for decades the hydro fairy
and her secret wartime cargo lie hidden
in the dark
Waters until
now
Frederick Sera is a maritime
archaeologist he has studied this area
for over 20
years I'm standing on the shores of Lake
tin it's a very dramatic Lake in Norway
it's got uh high mountains up to 1,000
MERS around it and uh the lake is very
deep so it actually goes down to 460
m
for decades this Lake had a big
secret and to be able to uncover that
secret the whole lake had to be
explored 1,500 ft is too deep for
divers so Frederick works with an expert
in remotely operated Vehicles Thor ulab
spirit so today we have the remotely
operated vehicle it is used to go down
to the Shipwreck so that we can film it
and also make a lot of other interesting
documentation they're equipping the ROV
with the latest multi-beam sonar
technology allowing them to probe the
darkest depths take it up and then we
can load a new profile and then start
doing the other tests yeah multibeam
Sonar fires sound waves to the lake
floor
the return signal displays the shape and
depth of the features
beneath it becomes then a very detailed
image and that's what we're looking at
that's what we want and Thor ulv knows
where to
look he's been fascinated by the story
of the Lost fairy for years and he was
one of the first to find the
wreck now he's back with powerful new
scanning equipment and cameras that will
finally finally give him the most
detailed record of what's down
there eventually a ghostly shape looms
into
view the icy depths of the freshwater
lake have preserved the decades old
Secret
oh there we go coming in there oh there
it is I see the
rain where are we now on the
starboard very
nice the super structure is still
standing there and we can see uh a lot
of things on board
[Music]
still yeah we only 3 and a half me met
above
it oh look that's a is that a railway
carriage or yes it is upside down it's
upside down who's been thrown over yeah
that's the
wheels the cargo on these carriages was
once destined for Nazi
Germany instead it lies deep in the
darkness of a Norwegian
Lake but why is the fery
[Music]
here for the very first time the Waters
of Lake tin drain away to reveal the
true
picture using multibeam Sonar data
combined with cuttingedge computer
Graphics the Lake's astonishing
underwater landscape comes clearly into
view
the first clue lies in the shape of the
valley
itself there are steep Banks which
descend 1,500 ft down to the bottom of
one of the deepest lakes in
Europe as the Waters of the lake drain
fully
away the drowned fery is brought back
into the light of day for the first time
in over 70
years
first the stern of the 170 ft long
vessel tilting
downwards then the wreckage of the
Railway
carriages and the captain's
[Music]
wheelhouse the spread of the wreckage is
firm evidence of a catastrophic sudden
sinking here is we can clearly see the
wreck and we can see the Wheelhouse up
here yeah and we can see there's
something behind here maybe the bow is
probably down in the
mud so what wrecked the
fery the answer is one of the most
daring sabotage operations of World War
II Norwegian resistance Fighters learn
about the Nazi heavy water shipment they
are ordered by London to stop it at all
costs the night before the fery departs
under cover of Darkness the sabur board
The Vessel and place a time bomb set to
detonate at a precise
moment then leave the ship to its
fate the sabur knew the stakes could be
higher they had to stop the
transportation to
Germany draining Lake tin reveals that
the ferry is precisely targeted to sink
in the deepest part of the
lake no Nazi diver can ever retrieve the
barrels of heavy water from these depths
but is the ferry carrying enough heavy
water to give Hitler an atomic
bomb draining Lake tin in Norway reveals
an Infamous Nazi nuclear secret strewn
across the lake
bed was there enough heavy water on
board to make the Nazis nuclear bomb
program go critically
after the ferry went down there was a
lot of speculation that the heavy water
on board the hydro had been replaced by
normal water because it was so lightly
guarded so we wanted to go down and take
up a barrel to prove that this was in
fact the heavy water that was being
shipped to
Germany the team has already examined
three barrels from the
depths
yeah testing samples taken from inside
the barrels proves that they do contain
heavy
water but was the fair's cargo large
enough to help Hitler build an atomic
bomb the only way to find out is to
probe the darkness of Lake tin and see
how many barrels are
left draining the Waters of this
Norwegian Lake unlocks the
answers amazingly still intact after
more than 70
years first one barrel on the deck then
two more spilled over the
side then two others 60 ft from the Rec
site that's Five Barrels visible around
the
recck well you can still see numbers on
the barrels
yeah we believe that maybe 10 barrels
floated because they were not
full and we have picked up three
barrels with at least 18 barrels
accounted for and using the scan data as
a guide the survey team can calculate
where the others
are we believe that most of the other
barrels are are actually on board the
ferry still underneath uh turned over
carriages that's about half a ton of
heavy
water enough to be a vital missing
component for the Nazis nuclear
reactor after the war those involved in
the German nuclear program said that the
loss of the heavy water was absolutely
decisive and stop their reactor program
in its
tracks
Nai secret weapons are deployed across
the
globe including the Indian
Ocean draining the waters here off the
coast of Western
Australia reveals two shattered
reck what appears to be a German
Merchant
ship and hmas
Sydney this Mighty Australian warship
disappears in November
1941 will draining hmas Sydney uncover
the mystery of what happened in the
National
disaster for the Australians the loss of
the Sydney almost became something like
a national trauma it was the pride of
the Australian
Navy not knowing about her final resting
place and the fade of a crew puzzled the
Australians for
decades after the war a German captain
Theodore deters claims to have defeated
the Sydney in
battle few Australians trust the German
Captain's account he had abandoned his
ship the Corin which was reportedly
nothing more than a cargo
vessel and there was no evidence of a
battle the only way to know for sure is
to find both
ships The Vessel geoss Sounder begins a
remarkable search off the coast of
Western
Australia equipped with new scanning
technology and supported by the
Australian government the Expedition is
led by one of the world's top wreck
Hunters David
Ms the atmosphere was very tense very
pressured I had to locate not just one
ship but two
ships the search area is huge but
amazingly the captain of the Coran left
in account containing vital Clues to
where his ship went
down Ms homes in on an area 125 Mi off
the
coast oh
yes this is exactly what you're looking
for after 12 days at Sea a
sign here we go here's the rest yeah
there is the shout out that's it that's
it that's
it just as Ms hoped by using the
captain's account as a guide he's found
the
Corin is he close to finding the Sydney
too everything all up
there just 4 days later the missing
warship comes into view it came up on
the screen suddenly and we knew
immediately that was the
Cindy it was just total elation that we
had found it we got it h that's it
that's HMS
Sydney at a depth of 1 and 1 half miles
it's too deep to dive so an ROV explores
the Rec
site it a gun it's it so what oh stop
stop right there that's it wow
oh look at
that among the ruins of a Savage fight
to the death are chilling reminders of
this ship as a war grave for
men but the underwater ROV camera only
gives us glimpses of the sunken
ships Now by combining the scan data
with computer generat ated
imagery it's possible to drain the
Indian
Ocean this is the hmas Sydney the pride
of a
Nation visible for the first time in
over 70
years the warship is pockmarked by
battle damage clear evidence of an epic
Close Quarters
firefight
Now using evidence from the seabed it's
possible to reconstruct a remarkable
struggle between the two lost ships and
show a Nazi secret weapon in
[Music]
action draining the Indian Ocean reveals
the Lost Australian warship hmas Sydney
but how did such a powerful vessel fall
victim to an ordinary merchant
ship the Coran Captain's account offers
some
Clues the announ of November Bak it was
November 19th
1941 a beautiful day with warm sunshine
as so often in the Indian Ocean the
visibility was
perfect
Suddenly at 400 p.m. the two ships eye
each other on the horizon 16 mil
apart the Coran signals that it's an
innocent Dutch
freighter but as the Sydney Moves In for
a closer inspection the Coran prepares
to unleash its deadly
Secrets the Nazi Captain knows his only
chance is to lure the warship into a
close Cor ERS
fight I let her come closer
still slowly langa
slowly then the Coran plays its
trick it appears to be an unarmed
Merchant
vessel but in reality the Nazi ship is
packed with the kind of deadly
technology that cu might have created
for James
Bond the corrin's mission in the Indian
Ocean was to prey on Allied Shipping it
was very much hit and run
tactics unaware of the Coran's true
identity the Sydney moves in
closer the two ships were about 1,000
meters apart well that's basically Point
Blank
Range thank
the enemy Cruiser was now coming within
the range that I considered suitable for
my
guns I gave the order and de
camouflage the Dutch flag was hauled
down and the German war flag ran
up according to the rules of War
concealed weapons are perfectly
legal but only if the ship reveals its
true colors before
firing
with the wreck of hmas Sydney now
drained of
seawater the first shocking evidence
caused by Coran's hidden weapons can be
seen in the clear light of
day the top of the captain's Bridge the
command center of the ship is
missing but
why on the cornate hidden from view a a
repurposed Army anti-tank gun
emerges and fires shattering the
Australian Captain's
Bridge the command structure of Sydney
would have been wiped out in the first
opening shot of the
battle rapid fire anti-aircraft guns now
rise up on hydraulic ramps cutting down
the Sydney's
crew
on the Sydney's main forward gun turrets
the tops have been blown
off and there's a blast hole in the
middle of one of the
guns what causes
this despite its innocent appearance the
Coran carries very heavy weapons perfect
for close-range
combat at the push of a button
counterweighted panels lift up to reveal
these powerful
guns at virtually Point Blank Range
their overwhelming Firepower knocks out
Sydney's forward gun
turrets it's probable that those guns
were taken out in the first 10 seconds
15 seconds of the
action although caught by surprise the
Sydney is still able to return fire and
hits the corran's engine room setting it
Ablaze the Nazi ship now prepares its
Sledgehammer
blow underneath the water line lie two
concealed torpedo
tubes and there are four more above the
water each hidden by a steel
flap it takes the Coran's crew just 30 2
seconds to prepare and fire a
torpedo they inflicted a great deal of
damage very quickly on the Australian
Cruiser guns firing the shells exploding
I mean it's absolute mayam hell on
Earth they were just being wiped out it
would have been absolute
Carnage 6:25 p.m. confident that the
Sydney is fatally wounded and most of
the crew already dead the Nazi Captain
ceases
fire
Victory never before in Naval History
had an armed Merchant vessel defeated a
cruiser an open
battle draining the water away from hmas
Sydney means crucial evidence of what
caused its final death blow can now be
seen a 90ft section of its Hull is
missing the Coran's Torpedoes caused
critical damage and a huge
explosion the Sydney's entire bow breaks
off causing the whole ship to plunge 1
and a half miles
down with 645 men on
board syney disappears entirely there
are no
survivors it's the most serious loss in
the Australian Navy's
history now we found the wreck we know
what happened and now we have an
accurate idea of what happened to the
ship but if the Sydney Was
Defeated why is the German Raider also
at the bottom of the Indian
Ocean there's a clue in the original
scale SCS of the sea
floor near the wreck is evidence of a
debris field caused by a massive
blast what happened to sink the
Corran the Nazi Ship Sails away
Victorious but it's been mortally
wounded in the
battle with the Coran's engines broken
down the huge fire on board anded a
number of mines in the hold which were
highly
explosive Commander dmas had no choice
whatsoever but to abandon
ship Hitler has similar Merchant Raiders
just like the
Coran to stop the ship's many secrets
from being discovered the crew then blow
up their own
vessel today the two ships still lie
just 13 miles apart on the
seabed the world's oceans hide Nazi
Secrets deep
underwater the Baltic
Sea draining the icy waters here reveals
a forgotten German aircraft carrier that
never saw battle graph
Zeppelin it disappeared more than 70
years
ago why is Hitler's only aircraft
carrier lying heavily damaged at the
bottom of the Baltic
Sea for decades the ultimate fate of the
naz's only aircraft carrier is a
mystery but then an oil survey vessel
begins SC scanning the Baltic
Sea first of all we came across
something that picked our
interest we found it using a multibeam
sonar after postprocessing the first
measurements indicate that it's about
260 M
long it's the largest wreck ever found
in the
Baltic
[Music]
wow
it was a really big
fight it was really
Spectacular Now diver and historian
Steven Burke is in the Baltic to
investigate the monster of the
deep the graph
Zeppelin When I first learned about the
graph Zeppelin nothing was known as to
what had happened to it at the end of
the war what happened after that was a
complete mystery
I made it my mission to go out and find
what the f of the ship had
been in the darkness nearly 290 ft down
there are only glimpses of the Lost
giant Timber decking on the flight
deck massive chains from one of the
anchors at 850 50 ft long could its
massive size be the very reason why this
Mighty vessel never played a full part
in the
War December
1938 Keel
Germany Hitler loved launching large
warships he took great pleasure in it um
he saw them as great National symbols
Herman Garing the head of the luwa is
Master of Ceremonies
the Nazis had huge Ambitions for the
vessel more than 40 Fighters bombers and
torpedo aircraft would have made it a
mighty War
Machine elevators would carry aircraft
from the lower deck up to the flight
deck planes would launch by
catapult
the thought of stukas taking off from an
aircraft carrier carrying out torpedo
and dive bombing attacks on Allied ships
it would have greatly strengthened their
Naval
position Winston Churchill sees the Nazi
aircraft carrier as a priority
Target the British were very concerned
that the Germans would complete the
graph
setl there was a significant
threat but the Nazis are slow to finish
this vast
warship though launched and seaworthy
final work is delayed time and time
again because it needs huge amounts of
construction
material contrary to appearances Germany
was very short of resources uh she was
very short of Steel because it was
thought the war would be short then it
was thought that the graph Zepplin might
not be complete in time to take part in
the
war so they had to stop building large
warships February
1945 the Nazis fa
defeat in early 1945 Admiral dures
issued a scotch Sur policy which was
that they were to destroy certain key
assets to prevent them falling into
Russian hands and one of those assets
was a graph
Zeppelin the graph Zeppelin is scuttled
by a German Wrecking Crew never to see
battle but that isn't the end of the
story it was abandoned on the river odor
but now it rests 200 miles away in the
middle of the
Baltic what why is the graph Zeppelin
here after the war the Russians seiz The
Vessel as
booty the Russians raised it so they
they sealed the holes they pumped the
water out and floated the
ship then they decided to use the graph
Zeppelin for a unique Cold War
experiment Steven Burke visits the
polish Naval Academy in Ginia to
investigate he's working with former
polish naval officer Adam olenic we have
a picture a lot of damage from different
military
materials Steven's looking for Clues to
explain the ship's final moments it's
less damage less damage less damage on
okay this is the Adam is part of a
Polish Navy team which positive
identified the graph
zein the enormity of this vessle was a
surprise it's hard to imagine if you
haven't seen it
before they us the mapping technology to
scan the
wreck by using the detailed sonar
scans now for the first time in over 70
years
evidence of the graph Zeppelin's final
moments can be
seen emptying the Baltic Sea of water
reveals an incredible
sight the 850 ft long drown
Leviathan The Wreck clearly shows
extensive damage caused by
explosives including a large 100t hole
in the
deck
it looked like the result of
Bowman the hole wasn't there when the
Germans abandoned the
ship so what caused
it in August
1947 the Russians want to see how much
punishment the graph Zeppelin could take
before it sinks so they planted a series
of bombs inside the
wreck 2,000 kilo bombs that are
detonated on the flight deck
they then sent in a series of waves of
aircraft to attack the ship with
bombs of over 90 drops only five or six
hit the Soviets have no aircraft carrier
of their own so by bombing the graph
Zeppelin they learned a lot about their
potential new enemies the British and
the
Americans sinking the graph Zeppelin
showed the Russian that aircraft
carriers were not necessarily as easy to
sink as they might have
thought they wanted to find out how you
sank them and they
diding Nazi secret technology reached
around the world and draining the oceans
reveals evidence of it in the most
surprising places
the English
Channel the grave of a remarkable vessel
equipped with a secret technology that
could have changed the course of the war
draining the oceans here reveals the
mystery of the Nazi ubo
u480 u480 you could call it the first
stealth submarine in
history this vessel vanished in
1945 carrying a lethal secret
technology what made this killer Nazi
sub
invisible August
1944 the D-Day Landings in France have
put Nazi Germany in
[Music]
Peril in August 1944 the situation for
the German OTS in the British channel
was rather grim
because it was one of the best defended
areas around the British
Isles the Allies have a highly effective
method for hunting the submarine
Raiders
sonar earlier in the war the Nazi ubot
Savaged Allied Shipping in the battle of
the
Atlantic largely by hunting in a on the
surface where sonar is of limited
use but by
1944 heavy surface patrols forc the uots
to operate completely
underwater making them much more
vulnerable to Allied
sonar this isn't Wolfpack Warfare
against convoys it's individual
submarines stalking individual
ships operations in a submarine in
English Channel at that time were
extremely
dangerous your chances of survival if
you're the commander of a ubot are about
50/50 the Nazis want to counter the
threat of
sonar the German answer to Sona
detection Wars uh developing some kind
of cloak of
invisibility by August 21st
1944 Hitler's designers have achieved
their dream of stealth
technology ubo Captain Hans yakim fer
and his crew lie in wait deep in the
English
Channel and the Allies never realize
he's
there it's
unprecedented he gets into the English
Channel and in five days he sinks four
ships and he gets
out it's the most devastating patrol car
out into the channel up to that
time it's quite
remarkable will draining the Waters of
the English Channel help explain this
Nazi
secret underwater archaeologist inis
McCartney investigates reports of a
uboat wreck about 20 mi off the coast of
Southern
England hidden 200 ft
down when you hit the water and you put
your hand on the downline and you're
swimming down to the wreck the sense of
anticipation is is just truly
incredible your first interaction with
this completely unseen object is can he
work out what it
is now for the first time the waters in
the English Channel drain
away and bring u480 into the clear light
of
day The Secret of the stealth submarine
is
revealed the entire surface of the ubot
is covered with rubber
[Music]
panels each panel has a series of tiny
regular
holes instead of reflecting sonar
signals back to an Allied warship these
rubber panels absorb them making it
effectively
invisible I put my hand on a a black
rubber panel and I was like I don't
believe what I've Just
Seen diminishing the effectiveness of
the other side sonar could well make the
difference between life and
death today in kale Germany one of efor
Ado's sister boats still survives
u480 wasn't a particular new design it
was the basic type 7 ubot only covered
with this special cloaking
device but draining u480 raises another
critical
question if it was
undetectable why is u480 at the bottom
of the English
Channel removing all the water means
that Clues to the Damage Done to u480
can now be
revealed it has sustained a critical
blow the stern section is broken off and
there's a hole in the pressure
hole what caused such devastating
damage faced with a modern high-tech
threat the Allies resort to a very
oldfashioned
response
mines the Trap that u480 fell victim to
was a secret mine
field February
1945 shipping lanes crisscross the
channel but all Allied vessels are
secretly warned not to travel in a
specific shipping Lane area and un known
to the ubot crew the British lay what's
called a deep trap
Minefield far below the
surface then
wait u48 returned to what had been its
old hunting grounds expecting to find
some more targets the navigational boys
were there so it seemed as if the route
was still being
used in fact it wasn't the British were
laying minefields and these came as a
very nasty
surprise
it was the exact point they knew you
thought where he was
going targeted killing based on
intelligence that's why you keep it
secret you're
blind
terrifying
320 lbs of explosive bursts a hole in
the submarine letting in tons of water
per
second there is no chance of
escape the secret stealth technology was
years ahead of its
time but in the end even its special
cloak of invisibility could not save
u480 from the Victorious
allies the Nazis Lost World War
II but the deadly Secrets they left
behind under the world's oceans are a
reminder of the extraordinary courage of
the men and women who brought the Nazis
down
[Music]
deep beneath the tropical waters of the
Gulf of Mexico lies a seething history
of piracy slavery and bitter conflict
the Gulf of Mexico is the wild west of
the sea and it's every man for himself
imagine if we could empty the oceans
letting the water drain away to reveal
the secrets of the seaf
Flor now we
can using the latest underwater scanning
technology piercing the Deep oceans and
turning the accurate data into 3D
images this time
why did a deadly German yubo end up at
the bottom of the ocean off the coast of
New Orleans within very short range the
hunter becomes the
hunted who was on board this mysterious
wreck from a time when pirates and slave
Traders ruled the
waves how did a single asteroid impact
in the Gulf of Mexico Wipe Out the
dinosaurs around the globe the base of
the food chain is knocked out and things
begin to starve and how did drilling for
oil result in one of the biggest
environmental disasters in US history in
theory that well should have been
easy draining the ocean shines new light
on the secrets of the Gulf of
Mexico
66 million years ago dinosaurs roam the
Earth then in a geological instant they
are wiped out around the
planet can draining the water from the
Gulf of Mexico explain
why the Story begins not in the Gulf but
over 1,500 M away in New
Jersey this former Quarry is one of the
most important fossil sites in the world
because here paleontologists discover a
mass prehistoric graveyard this is the
boundary between the Cretaceous Period
the age of the dinosaurs and the age
that comes after that the Paleo Gene and
what we have here is a bone bed where we
have about 25 fossils per square meter
paleontologists have never found an inpl
dinosaur bone 1 cm above that Extinction
layer anywhere on the planet the absence
of dinosaur fossils above this layer can
mean only one thing they were wiped out
by a sudden cataclysmic event 66 million
years ago whatever took out the
dinosaurs was Global terrible and
instantaneous experts have offered many
answers but but only one is widely
accepted by far the Leaning explanation
is that an asteroid hit the earth 66
million years ago and Unleashed hell on
Earth and took out the dinosaurs in 75%
of
life scientists scour the planet looking
for evidence of asteroid
strikes but none of the impact craters
that they find are big enough and the
right age to be the culprit then in
Mexico's Yucatan Peninsula they find a
surprising
wead Mario robayo is an expert in a
remarkable natural phenomenon found all
over the region sink holes known locally
as
[Music]
senes formed by the erosion of soft
Limestone they can be h hundreds of feet
deep exploring them requires years of
experience there are many caves so it is
easy for any inexperienced diver to go
into one of these caves and get lost or
run out of air when you are in
there and that can be
[Music]
fatal Mario discovers that many of the
enotes are linked through deep
Subterranean
channels but that's not all they also
display a remarkably similar structure
normally in sedimentary rocks like
Limestone you expect the beding to be
horizontal we saw a layer of rocks that
are
vertical and on top of them the rocks
are again
horizontal this means that in this
period of time time some big geological
phenomenon happened that tilt them to
that position when seen from above an
extraordinary picture begins to emerge
the cenotes form an
outline it looks like the rim of a
gigantic crater the most likely
explanation is that a massive asterid
stripe reshaped this region and then the
sink holes formed in fault lines around
it Edge could this be the crater that's
linked to the death of the
dinosaurs today millions of years after
it was created the heart of the impact
site lies concealed not just under the
waters of the Gulf of Mexico but under
several thousand ft of sedimentary rock
the only way to calculate its age and
see if it dates from the demise of the
dinosaurs is to analyze rocks from the
crater itself
to really understand impact cratering we
actually need to pull rocks from Ground
Zero we need to find a place where we
know that the the damage has been the
greatest in order to get a sense of the
way impact craters
work in 2016 an international team of
scientists drilled down from this
specially adapted oil
platform and so we're pulling up
Limestone after limestone after
Limestone we're getting ages from the
fossils within them we know we're at 48
or 50 million years but we're not yet at
66 right and then things suddenly jumped
in time the team hits a layer of melted
rock indicating an asteroid strike and
samples confirm that the rocks are 66
million years old the exact moment when
the dinosaurs
died next the team analyzes the rocks to
calculate the asteroids
power comparing their data to that
generated by nuclear bomb
tests we can come up with an estimate of
the amount of energy released and that
turns out to be about 10 billion
[Music]
hoshima using this data it's possible
for the very first time to create a 3 D
visualization of the crater Now hidden
deep beneath the Earth and discover how
a single asteroid impact in the Gulf of
Mexico could wipe out dinosaurs around
the
globe first the entire Gulf must be
drained away as the water recedes it
reveals a vast continental shelf running
around the coastline the crumpled plane
is thick with sediment but the crater is
still here hidden under thousands of
feet of
rock 66 million years of geology must
now be rolled back draining away layer
upon layer of sedimentary rock until the
impact site begins to emerge a sight
that no living creature has witnessed
for 66 million years the crater is
immense over half a mile deep and 120 M
wide
around its Edge Towers the outer rim
formed by Rock ejected from deep within
the Earth's
crust Now by studying the crater's
profile it's possible to determine the
size and speed of the asteroid it's over
7 m wide and it travels at 40,000
mph and the crater's dimensions tell us
something else 30,000 cubic miles of
rock are displaced here vast amount BS
hurled into the atmosphere setting off a
devastating chain of
events it blows a hole in the ground
about the size of the state of
Massachusetts now all that rock it gets
pulverized thrown up through the Earth's
atmosphere starts to orbit the planet
and when that rock comes back in it's
got a tremendous amount of potential
gravitational energy it heats up the
atmosphere to toaster oven or Pizza Oven
temperatures frying everything that
doesn't have a place to hide almost
every living creature within 600 mil is
killed by this deadly Fireball but those
farther away do not Escape later that
day the tsunami waves wash up on the
shore these could have been hundreds of
feet tall maybe even a half a mile tall
when they hit here and they would have
run up through the continent animals
that are still alive would have heard
the wave coming for them but wouldn't
have seen it in the darkness but the
asteroid strike becomes comes a truly
Global disaster for one specific reason
where it hits
Earth this part of the planet contains
rocks high in Sulfur on impact the
sulfur is vaporized and blasted high
above the Earth well that sulfur
combines with the atmosphere and becomes
sulfate aerosols and sulfate aerosols
are excellent in blocking sunlight this
deadly Cloud shrouds the planet and the
Earth begins to cool
by studying the crater in more detail
it's possible to see new evidence of how
the crater's shape makes the sulfur
Cloud even more deadly the Northeast Rim
is open the asteroid hits deep water
here absorbing some of the impact and 30
minutes later the ocean rushes back
in water vapor from this tsunami
combines with the sulfur to form
sunlight blocking gases and even Lar
larger
quantities the plankton in the ocean
can't do photosynthesis and pretty soon
the base of the food chain is knocked
out and things begin to
starve lack of sunlight means the entire
planet experiences an average cooling of
47° f for up to 16
years only the toughest plants and
animals
survive the dinosaurs do
not one question remains was this event
unique or could it happen again this
time wiping out hum kind there are other
near Earth objects out there asteroids
just like the one that took out the
dinosaurs and we do not know where they
all are every day scientists are
discovering more and more asteroids that
have the power to Menace our
earth now we think we've tracked all the
big ones so we don't think there's
another event that's just around the
corner uh but that doesn't mean we
shouldn't keep making sure given the uh
the
circumstances as we drain the Gulf of
Mexico further it's possible to reveal
areas where humans are drilling
thousands of feet below the seab B to
exploit a natural resource formed a 100
million years ago
oil but how did a failure while Drilling
in the Gulf of Mexico turn into the
biggest oil spill in US
history the economy of the Gulf of
Mexico is driven by oil this vast oilr
Basin accounts for 177% of total us
crude oil production nearly half of
America's oil refining capacity sits
along the Gul
Coast but it's offshore that the scale
of the infrastructure needed to to bring
oil to the surface is truly
staggering using the latest data and
visualization techniques draining away
the Waters of the Gulf of Mexico exposes
an extraordinary Underwater World
normally hidden in the dark depths of
the
ocean but how did an accident here cause
the worst environmental disaster in the
history of the Gulf of
Mexico
[Music]
hump Jacks like these introduced in the
1920s can only extract oil in very small
quantities on land an old well like this
is perhaps producing only 10 barrels per
day of oil this is old technology this
is on the Twilight of an oil field you
can tell that because it's nodding up
and down that means that the pressure in
that Reservoir down there is low it's
about ready to be
finished in the 1940s oil companies
discover a far more productive Source
below the Waters of the Gulf of Mexico
here the oil doesn't need to be pumped
it flows and the reason lies deeply
embedded in the unique geology of the
gulf the Gulf of Mexico is one of the
more oil rich areas on the planet
because out Beyond us was once an
ancient swamp 300 million years ago
that swamp now is not only under the
water it's underneath the Earth and as a
result of pressure and heat all of that
organic material has been transformed
into
oil to produce an oil field three things
are essential a layer of carogen the
organic compound which creates oil a
permeable Rock such as Sandstone known
as Source Rock for the oil to accumulate
in and a trap a layer of impermeable
Rock above to prevent the oil
dissipating by drilling down through
this hard layer it's possible to extract
the oil and gas from the reservoir below
and the gulf's continental shelf
provides the perfect base for offshore
drilling
platforms when you look out over the
Gulf of Mexico and you see this flat
expanse of water most people don't
realize that this is very shallow you
can go 50 to 100 m out but it's only 100
ft deep
since the first platform was constructed
just a mile offshore the network has
expanded greatly around
3,500 platforms now sit off the
coast but it's only by draining the
ocean that it's possible to see the
sheer scale of the infrastructure hidden
beneath the waves as the water recedes
these huge structures are left high and
dry there are more oil platforms Ms here
than in the rest of the world
combined in the 1970s companies begin to
move off the continental shelf into ever
deeper waters to tap into even bigger
reserves operating in the gulf's very
deepest regions up to 10,000 ft below
the waves where conditions are extremely
hostile it is completely black
temperature down there is just above
freezing
you're you're drilling another sometimes
20,000 ft below the seabed and it gets
extremely hot so you have this big
contrast between something that's very
hot to something that's very cold let
alone the extremely high pressures that
we
have today there are around 50 deep
waterer rigs cited in the
Gulf continuing to drain its Waters
beyond the continental shelf reveals the
huge scale of infrastructure needed to
bring oil to the surface from these
super deep Wells clusters of well heads
control the flow of oil and gas from
deep below the seabed the pressure in
the wells can reach up to 22,000 lb per
square
in the well heads connect to a central
manifold up to 100 ft High which
controls the flow of oil and gas from
across the oil field up to the
production rig
the rig separates the oil and gas before
they're transported to Shore by pipeline
some stretching for hundreds of miles as
they wind their way along the
seabed an incredible 43,000 Mi of
pipeline snakes across the floor of the
gulf with oil reserves close to shore
now becoming depleted companies continue
to search the Gulf of Mexico for new
more productive oil fields special rigs
costing nearly half a million dollars a
day to operate drill exploration Wells
called Wildcats reaching miles below the
sea one such rig is called the Deep
waterer Horizon the deep water Horizon
is an exploration drilling rig we use
what we call mobile drilling units to
come in and drill the initial well if we
find oil we run casing down there we
cement it off and then we move that
exploration rig off location and then
come back later to put on the production
equipment in 2010 the Deep waterer
Horizon strikes oil 50 Mi off the coast
of Louisiana in an area cod named Mondo
in theory that well should have been
easy in that the water depth about 5,000
ft we have been Drilling in 5 ,000 ft of
water since
1979 the pressure wasn't too high either
however we are in a very potentially
dangerous
industry and now another major story
developing in the Gulf of Mexico 11
people are missing after an explosion
and fire on an offshore oil rig the
explosion happened aboard a mobile
offshore drilling unit called The Deep
waterer Horizon it erupted with 126
people on board the cement lining
designed to seal the well before the rig
moves away has a leak in it allowing oil
and gas to force their way up to the r
and ignite
it after burning for 2 days the rig
sinks the 11 missing workers are never
found in the aftermath 60,000 barrels of
oil per day Escape into the
Gulf with the well head a mile
underwater and the oil pressure so high
Engineers can't stop the
flow in the immediate aftermath of the
disaster even while the well was flowing
the government stopped all Deep Water
Drilling in the Gulf of Mexico and
rightly so until we could figure out
what had happened and what you need to
do to be sure not only it doesn't happen
again but if it does happen that you
have equipment so that you can stop it
immediately to seal the Mondo well
Engineers design a solution from scratch
a capping stack to latch over the well
head working remotely at incredible
depths by the time the well is sealed 87
days after the blowout nearly 5 million
barrels of crude oil have escaped
the worst environmental disaster ever to
strike the Gulf of
Mexico the wreck of the deep waterer
Horizon Now lies on the
seabed but it's not alone human Commerce
began in the Gulf of Mexico hundreds of
years before the oil and gas industry
took hold as the water continues to
drain away an extraordinary relic of the
Region's Maritime history is about to be
revealed from a time when the gulf
became a super highway for pirates and
Smugglers trading in the most valuable
commodity of the
age human
life oil and gas exploration means the
seabed of the Gulf of Mexico is surveyed
in fine
detail and the search for oil regularly
uncovers long lost
shipwrecks including a mysterious ship
150 Mi south of New
Orleans as the water of the Gulf of
Mexico continues to drain away it will
be exposed to the sky for the first time
in 200 years giving an extraordinary
insight into a period renowned for
piracy smuggling and
slavery who was on this mysterious ship
and what was its
[Music]
cargo sitting at the mouth of the great
Mississippi River New Orleans in the
early 19th century expands rapidly New
Orleans was basically a bustling
Maritime ento I mean this was one of the
largest ports in the Western Hemisphere
and it was situated centrally in the
Gulf of Mexico and so you have hundreds
of Ships coming and going importing
exporting all sorts of different kinds
of trade goods but you're also seeing an
increase in illicit activity from slave
trade to smuggling and and this place is
just
booming hard evidence of this
extraordinary period of Maritime history
is extremely
rare then in 2011 an oil company
identifies a wreck giving it the name
the montere this particular shipwreck
lies on the seaf Flor at approximate
death up to 4,500 ft or almost a mile
which makes it really difficult to get
to but it also means it's going to be
that much better preserved because the
temperature at that depth is 4° C and
that really slows the rate of
decomposition the team launches a
state-of-the-art remotely operated
vehicle or ROV to investigate the ROV
takes 4 hours to get down to the
seafloor and so you know there's this
anticipation
when the ROV hits the floor and cruises
up to this particular site and we lay
our eyes on the Shipwreck for the first
time we're astounded we're excited
because what we're looking at is a
largely intact ship almost a mile deep
in the Gulf of Mexico and it was just
mind-blowing as the ROV travels over the
wreck it sends back tantalizing glimpses
of the ship and its contents at this
depth in the ocean it's Pitch Black
there's no light you can't see anything
unless you light it up so when we're
working on sites like this in particular
we're only getting snapshots or small
glimpses of the site itself we don't
have the entire picture while we're
viewing the ROV
footage the ROV also captures precise
data from onboard sonar
equipment combining this with the latest
visual visualization techniques it's now
possible to drain the ocean and pull the
plug on more of the Gulf of Mexico
letting archaeologists view the wreck
from any angle and examine it in
unexpected detail will seeing it for the
first time in 200 years helped them
discover what it was doing how it came
to lie on the sead and the biggest
mystery of all who was on
board as the the water receives the ship
is
revealed the bow sheathed in Copper to
protect against marine organisms still
intact and the anchor still
stowed chain plates once used to secure
the rigging indicated had two wooden
masts long lost to the
ocean with the water gone six Cannon lay
exposed to the sky and around the stern
lying on the seafloor a cach of
muskets what struck me was this was a
ship that was very long and narrow
particularly at the bow it struck me as
almost being like a Clipper ship a
specific type of vessel that came into
the four really in the early
1800s Clippers were perfectly suited to
the Gulf of Mexico due to their shallow
draft ideal for navigating the gulf's
coastal Waters and Marshy Bayou what
also struck us was that it was armed it
had Cannon and there were muskets was it
a warship was it something else is it a
privateer Privateer is basically an
individual that has written permission a
letter of Mark or a letter of commission
from a respective government giving them
permission to capture ships to make
incursions on enemy soil uh in the name
of that particular country privateering
is basically state sponsored piracy in
which the Privateer gets a cut of the
action and the rest goes to the state
that's
licensed in the first two decades of the
19th century there are hundreds of
privateers in the Gulf of
Mexico but as the ocean drains even
further away from around the Monteray
there's a Twist to this story the wreck
is not Al alone as the water disappears
a complete picture of the entire sea
floor begins to emerge for the very
first time revealing the remains of two
other ships each containing further
Clues it's really exciting to have one
shipwreck but when all of a sudden you
go from 1 to
three it gets incrementally more
exciting because now we're not talking
about just one wreck we're talking about
a potential
Convoy wreck a the first ship discovered
is heavily armed with Cannon and muskets
for close quarter combat leaving
researchers to think it could be a
privateer with wck B it's clear that the
wooden Hull has been consumed by the
ocean but its cargo is still
intact it's carrying animal hides a
valuable commodity at the time and
frequently traded treated and rolled for
shipment they're well observed by the
cold Waters Rex SE exposed to the sky
for the first time in 200 years is a
larger three masted vessel but amongst
this wreck there's no cargo to be found
what does that mean well it means the
ship was either sailing in ballast that
is empty or it had a cargo that was
perishable and that perishable cargo
could have been everything from rice or
grain to one possibility being a very
sobering thought and that is it could
have been carrying people it may have
been a vessel engaged in the illegal
slave
trade the transatlantic slave trade sees
slaves violently captured and shipped
from West Africa and then forced to work
on us
plantations although owning slaves
remains lawful the import of new ones is
outlawed by Congress in
1807 Great Britain also bans the trade
and uses its Navy
to hunt down and capture slave
ships with much money still to be made
Smugglers continue to bring captured
African men women and children through
the Gulf of Mexico and into its Maze of
channels and waterways aiming for New
Orleans and its slave markets is Rex SE
involved in this brutal callous business
now we didn't see manles or anything of
that sort but in this period when it's
lost it's entirely possible as we know
from other cases that people were simply
locked Below in the hold and with those
that were most capable of trying to
escape being tied
up the team begins to piece together the
evidence and thinking about these three
ships as a convoy we can hypothesize a
variety of scenarios the first would be
it's an armed escort with two merchant
ships that need protection to get from
one port to
another it could be a
privateer with two surprises that it
captured in looking at the cargo on the
second ship we have Stacks and
stacks of coow hides those would have
brought a great price at the market even
if you were
smuggling to unravel the mystery further
they select a range of artifacts and
bring them to the
surface they could reveal once and for
all who was on board one of the unique
things about this particular shipwreck
monter shipwreck a was the Cannons and
the presence of muskets those were all
British military musket types they were
absolutely ubiquitous in this region
during the first half of the 19th
century so having British muskets on a
ship does not mean that it's a British
vessel the crew nationality remains a
mystery but there are other clues that
may tell us what caused the ships to
sink a portion of the collection that
was recovered were navigational tools
the importance of these tools was so
great that you would have wanted to have
taken those with you and so leaving them
on the ship is for boating and you know
it suggests that maybe everyone
perished the Gulf of Mexico is notorious
for a particularly violent force of
nature hurricanes giving rise to one
likely
scenario all three of them were running
together in what clearly was a very
violent
storm you had a quick moment to look on
the horizon see the other guys there and
then their lights disappear if it's at
night or they disappear in a Squall and
the next thing you know the gulf is
coming over your own decks and you're
being dragged down Into the Depths and
into the darkness the M group of rexs
provides a new insight into the maritime
history of the Gulf of Mexico at a
turning point in US history the monter
shipwrecks are are important because
they're evidence of that transition to
the birth of a new nation how continued
while the Spanish Empire crumbled why
New Orleans was such an important part
of this inter Regional burgeoning global
trade and that's what those shipwrecks
speak to and that's what they're
symbolic
of the Monteray recks are not alone as
the water drains away further leaving
the darkest depths of the Gulf of Mexico
exposed one of the most extraordinary
stories of all is about to be revealed a
state-of-the-art World War II submarine
not America but Germany what was Nazi
submarine u166 doing in the Gulf of
Mexico and how did it meet its
[Music]
end December 11th
1941 Hitler declares war on the United
States
States when the US enters the war a new
Battleground opens up the Gulf of
Mexico today by draining away its dark
Waters it's possible to reveal secrets
from this desperate period period of
conflict when a ruthless battle to rule
the waves comes to America's own Shores
and solve a mystery which has baffled
historians for over 70
years immediately after entering World
War II the US faces a deadly Peril off
its eastern Seaboard Nazi
OTs their objective is to disrupt Allied
Shipping Bound for Europe at the
source the ubot commanders are highly
experienced having honed their skills in
battle since
1939 the United States is completely
unprepared for them ships were escorted
across the North Atlantic in convoys
both ways but once they got into
American Coastal Waters they were
unescorted and they were therefore easy
targets for the ubot to make matters
worse the US government fails to impose
a blackout ships sailing along the coast
at night are perfectly silhouetted
Sitting Ducks this was a key
vulnerability the Germans noticed and
they s their submarines in to exploit
it German submarine commanders call it
American shooting
season between January and June of
1942 more tonnage is sunk off the US
Coast than the Allies have lost during
the previous two and a half years as the
Nazis try to starve Britain of vital
supplies the uots then take the war into
the Gulf of
Mexico and the reason is oil most of the
world's oil at this time came through
the Gulf of Mexico uh hence it was the
equivalent to the Arabian Gulf
today it's not just oil tankers any
allied ship is seen as fair game the
yubo skipper did not want to pass up on
the opportunity to sync what might be a
valuable cargo of a specific commodity
be it food stuffs be it Machinery or
parts he couldn't know for certain but
he did know that if he shouldn't ship to
the bottom he was aiding the German war
effort one such ship is the Robert E Lee
the Roberty Lee was a passenger
freighter it was coming from Trinidad up
to New Orleans and it actually was
carrying uh American construction
workers and also a lot of other uh uh
passengers that were victims on previous
OT
sinkings as the Robert E Lee approaches
New Orleans
u166 is on
patrol one of the latest German long
range submarines
u166 is capable of traveling across the
Atlantic without the need to refuel a
thoroughbred ocean Predator commanded by
battle hardened Captain Hans Gunter
kouman Hans Gunter kman had not had a
lot of success during this Mission he
had sank a couple small boats including
one that was uh just a few tons that she
bore the same name as his wife gerries
and so soon as he saw a large vessel of
over 5,000 tons it was a big Target and
it was it was an opportunity for him to
get some tonnage under his
belt the details of the battle including
the fate of u166 for years remains one
of the Gulf of Mexico's greatest
Mysteries Rob church is a marine
archaeologist for a company performing
surveys of the sea floor for the oil and
gas industry when a wreck is discovered
his job is to assess its historical
importance so this is the typical
inspection class ROV it's a 3,000 met
rated system on this particular one
right now we have three camera arrays
here we have the stereo cameras for
collecting 3D video
we have the HD camera above them for
collecting high resolution video we also
have a seven function manipulator arm
which allows us to be able to pick up
things on the sea Flor collect samples
also uh set out experiments Etc and then
we have the scanning Sono this allows us
to detect Targets on the SEF FL to
inspect or we can also use it to
navigate around ship
RS while conducting an oil pipeline
survey using an ROV similar to this Rob
Church comes across a
wreck we approached from the stern and
you could see the railing you could see
the decks of that passenger freighter
and there was no doubt at that point
that we were looking at the Robert El
Le this was a thrilling moment and to
see a boat uh like the robery Lee which
is really a beautiful Rec site it it was
[Music]
incredible over 5,000 ft down the ROV
scans the site collecting valuable
[Music]
data from this it's possible to drain
away the ocean and see the drowned
vessel as she is today but this time
exposed to the
sunlight as the water pours away the
wreck of the Roberty Lee is revealed in
extraordinary detail providing new
evidence on her final
moments
the bridge is gone unable to withstand
the forces of drag as the ship plummeted
through the
water the deck gun on the stern is in
the stored position showing the attack
is sudden and
unexpected and lying next to the wreck
are two lifeboats the speed with which
the ship goes down does not give the
crew time to deploy them experts
calculate that it takes just 3 minutes
for the Robert E Lee to sink but one
important part of the puzzle remains
unanswered what happened to the ubo that
fired the deadly torpedo as the water
continues to drain away from the wreck
of the Rober E Lee one of the Gulf of
Mexico's biggest Maritime Mysteries is
about to be
solved
July 30th
1942 the German submarine
u166 fires a fatal shot at the merchant
vessel Robert E Lee off the coast of New
Orleans it sinks in 3 minutes but the
Robert E Lee is not alone it's escorted
by a submarine Chaser Patrol craft
566 Captain by Herbert Claudius the
indications are that the ubot had no
idea that the patrol craft was bearing
down on them they were proceeding at
Periscope death watching the Roberty Le
sink it wasn't until the patrol craft
got within range and began actively
pinging sonar against the hole that they
first apparently realized that they were
under attack at that moment and began to
dive within very short range the hunter
becomes The Hunted as Patrol craft 566
passes over the ubot captain Claudius
fires two rounds of depth
charges unable to confirm a kill he
turns his attention to rescuing
survivors of the Robert El Le the fate
of
u166 remains
unknown 2 Days Later a US Coast Guard
Plane spots a ubo
surfacing 140 Mi away it drops a single
depth
charge and the ubo
disappears the plane crew is credited
with sinking
u166 but despite extensive scanning of
the seafloor no trace of a wreck is ever
found finding something that so many
people had looked for for so long it's
kind of um you know it it takes an
element of
luck studying a sonar scan of the seabed
around the Robert El Church spots a
mysterious object less than 2 mi away
from the rack so as I first saw the the
image I realized it had potential but it
was about it was about 50 60 ft short of
the dimensions of a type 9C German yubo
what was this mysterious wreck 140 Mi
away from where
u166 was believed to have sunk could it
be the missing sub further F draining of
the ocean uncovers the truth as the
water recedes light begins to pour onto
this mystery vessel the conning Tower of
a German yubo gradually appears its
antenna unretracted indicating it dived
suddenly and under
duress next its Hull is exposed to the
sky for the first time in over 70 years
the configuration of the conning Tower
and deck guns exactly matches the
missing
u166 and from another angle the reason
the sonar image is short suddenly
becomes clear the uo's bow is missing
blown off by a massive
explosion as the water continues to
drain away the missing section is
revealed lying 500 ft
away a depth charge alone could not have
caused such catastrophic damage
so what happened it appears that after
one of the de charges breached the
pressure hole that it probably set off
an internal
explosion which then ripped the bow
section
off when the submarine dived perhaps
Torpedoes became loose it was more
likely that an explosion would occur
this was a successful dep charge attack
and it was clear that this was actually
sunk as claimed by the submarine
Chaser 22 people lost their lives on the
Rober E Lee and all 52 perished on the
u166 the two reck are now considered a
war grave and cannot be salvaged
draining the ocean is the only way to
bring the Rex to the surface and in the
process set the record straight with the
ubo discovered lying less than 2 miles
from the Robert El Le there can be no
doubt who sank it the kill is now
credited to Herbert Claudius
captain of Patrol craft
566 soon after the sinking of
u166 the tide begins to turn in the
battle of the Atlantic
inevitably the Allies were able to push
back against the ubot assault thanks to
a variety of factors increased
surveillance more convoys as well as the
ability to strike from the air the OTS
were steadily
defeated
nevertheless during the second world war
while operating in US Waters the German
Navy sends
69 Allied ships to the bottom of the
ocean with the loss of only 12
OTS of those only one submarine is sunk
in the Gulf of Mexico
u166 looking below the w Waters of the
Gulf of Mexico has solved long lost
Mysteries and brought deadly secrets
back to the
surface showing that the story of North
America through trade war and even the
death of the
dinosaurs can only be fully seen and
understood by draining the
oceans
beneath the Clear Blue Waters of the
Mediterranean lie Treasures of ancient
empires relics of their bloody
wars and secrets of the seismic forces
that shaped them lost beneath the
waves until
now imagine if we could empty the oceans
letting the water drain away to reveal
the secrets of the
seafood now we
can using the latest underwater scanning
technology piercing the
devotions and turning accurate data into
3D
images this time what apocalyptic
disaster triggered the collapse of
Europe's first
civilization can an extraordinary 2 and
1 half th000 yearold shipwreck unlock
the secrets of Ancient Greece how did
these deadly objects turn ancient Rome
into a
superpower and why does the Sin City of
the Roman Empire lie abandoned beneath
the
waves
ancient people call it the Middle Sea
the center of the Known World the
Egyptians Greeks and Romans build Mighty
civilizations upon its
Shores Empires battle for Supremacy
across its
Waters cities grow rich and Powerful
through trade the Mediterranean becomes
a super highway connecting cultures that
will shape the modern world but only by
draining the sea can we reveal its
biggest and most terrifying secret what
happened on this spectacular Greek
island to Doom an entire
civilization we must have thought this
was it the end of the
world
3,600 years ago 15 centuries before the
Roman Empire a mysterious people
dominate the
Mediterranean we call them the
Minoans their home is on
Creed here they build magnificent
temples and palaces and decorate them
with stunning fresco
celebrating their love of life and of
[Music]
nature but there's a darker side
too the minan Royal Palace at nasus is
said to contain a labyrinth home to the
Minotaur a fearsome creature part man
part bull with a terrible appetite for
human flesh
but apart from a Grizzly myth much about
the minoan world Still Remains a mystery
we can't decipher their language we only
have their archaological remains but
what that tells us I think is that they
were extremely imaginative uh they were
extremely adventurous uh and that they
developed a sophisticated hierarchical
society that was capable of producing
elements of art and architecture which
still Astound us today
historians do know that the Minoans
spread across the Mediterranean trading
olive oil and pottery for gold and ivory
growing ever richer and more powerful
and then in the 15th century BC their
ancient civilization begins to fade from
the pages of
history for centuries no no one knows
why until scientists start to look
closely at the nearby island of
Santorini Santorini it has this very
very calm
water it's almost like it plays with you
and deceives you looking at this view
you would never imagine how dangerous it
once was and how dangerous it is the
island is famous for its spectacular
Jagged Cliffs which Tower above a
beautiful natural
Harbor but what created them and can
they help explain the downfall of the
menow marine geologist Evie nomu
believes that crucial Clues May lie deep
beneath Santorini's Tranquil Waters as I
was born in sorini I wanted to study the
area to reveal their
secret being a marine geologist means
that you are having access to the Mystic
world of the sea so you can see features
that nobody else can
see she harnesses the latest multibeam
sonar technology to scan the depths of
the huge
Bay by transforming her data into a
powerful computer
imagery it's possible to drain away the
Waters of the
Mediterranean and reveal Santorini's
terrifying
secret the sheer Cliffs Tower a th000 ft
above sea
level and drop a further thousand ft to
the seaf
flu framing a vast Basin large enough to
hold 10,000 Olympic
stadiums the Basin is a huge
crater and Santorini itself is the
remnant of a gigantic
volcano but that's not all on the rim of
the crater more evidence of Santorini's
violent
past
undiscovered until
1967 these shattered ruins are all that
remain of a once thriving city known
today as
actii it was destroyed when the volcano
erupted and buried under so much Ash
that it remained hidden for three and a
half thousand years it's almost like a
window back in time where you can see
how it was when it was
destroyed and deep in the ruins
archaeologists discover something
remarkable these Stone steps were not
broken by the Ash and lava from a
volcano they were Shattered by an
earthquake when the earthquake happened
everyone fled their
town but then they came back to start
rebuilding their homes and this is
exactly what we're seeing
here believing the danger over people
move furniture into the streets so they
can start repairing their
houses we're seeing the beds placed
outside of their homes we're seeing the
stones and mud getting ready to be used
to rebuild these
homes but but then they are struck by an
apocalypse the first stage of the
eruption is so powerful that it engulfs
actii and suffocates the whole island in
a thick layer of
debris and the date of this cataclysmic
eruption around
1625 BC the same time as the Minoans
begin to disappear from the pages of
history but how could a single eruption
trigger the collapse of a great
civilization based on an island 70 miles
away until recently most scientists have
focused only on the evidence above
ground but Evie nomu believes that once
again the re real Clues lie
underwater scientists have been occupied
studying only their own land geology so
we are starting mapping the CFL in order
to find out the total volume of that big
destructive
eruption Evie heads outside the great
crater to hunt for new evidence on the
seabed and what she finds is
extraordinary proof of the sheer scale
of this
eruption as the Waters of the
Mediterranean reede still further they
reveal wide Stone Terraces Fanning out
from the mouth of the
volcano the size of 20 story
buildings they point to one
cause
they're called pyroclastic flows
torrents of superheated gas and molten
rock the bastic flow can cover
everything they travel like a hurricane
they can destroyed everything on their
pass because of the high temperature up
to 1,000
Cel when they hit the sea the
pyroclastic flow cool and become solid
ramparts of
rock around Santorini they stretch for a
staggering 20 miles in every
direction evidence of multiple eruptions
lasting for
[Music]
Days by measuring the stone Terraces
scientists calculate that the volcano
throws out 14 cubic miles of debris an
eruption far more powerful than they had
ever
imagined it's one of the biggest
volcanic explosions in the history of
the
planet let's try to imagine what this
eruption looked like if you were sitting
somewhere in any of the neighboring
Islands it would have appeared like the
end of the
world at first the volcano blasts out a
column of superheated debris more than
20 M
high this huge funnel of black ash and
Cloud could have been seen going all the
way to the sky some of the volcanic
plume Falls to Earth many miles from
santarini it would have been raining
pomus on the surrounding Islands but now
the volcano unleashes its most
devastating surprise
and in its path lies Creek the center of
the minoan
world 70 M from Santorini the Minoans on
cre see the soaring column of Ash and
smoke from the erupting
volcano but they have no idea of the
disaster to come the volcano blasts
millions of tons of lava into the sea
triggering wave after wave of powerful
tsunamis when the tsunami arrived in
Creed they were probably taken totally
by surprise imagine seeing this wall of
water in some places 10 m High advancing
in it must have looked like that this
was the end of the world totally
unexpected the Wrath of the
Gods entire Coastal communities are
Swept Away by waves up to 30 ft tall
ports are destroyed and ships smashed to
pieces and the gods aren't finished
yet after the eruption and the tsunamis
another disaster is looming clouds of
volcanic ash cast a deadly PA over the
whole
Mediterranean dramatically Cooling the
Earth there were a series of effects
from the eruption that together fatally
weakened the Manan
civilization a tsunami event a Divine
event the destabilization of their
economy the failure of harvests over
several years that was the moment when
Manon civilization started to
[Music]
die without their ports and ships the
men ens lose their Mastery over the
Mediterranean Invaders challenge their
power and as the sun sets on the
collapsing minoan
civilization new powers
arise 500 M from creep just off the
coast of Cyprus the draining Waters of
the Mediterranean reveal a remarkable
Discovery almost 2 and a 12,000 years
old what can it tell us about the lives
the power and the pleasures of the
ancient
Greeks in the centuries after the fall
of the Minoans the city states of Greece
produce dazzling art and
architecture forging ideas in
mathematics democracy and theater that
still shape our
world
the Greeks take to the sea in their
wooden sailing ships risking their lives
to explore colonize and trade with each
other hundreds of boats shuttle across
the Mediterranean linking settlements in
Africa Asia and Europe they are the
lifeblood of Greek
civilization but these ships are a
mystery only a few remnants have
survived to offer a glimpse into how
they worked and what they
carry until
now a shipwreck recently discovered in
the Seas of Cyprus is helping to bring
this Lost World back to
life archaeologist Stella deisa and her
team are unlocking the Rex Secrets will
be to to remove any
where did it come
from what was it
carrying and why did it
sink it's pretty deep so it takes a
while when you're diving before you can
see the sea
bottom it looks all very higgledy pigley
it looks like well someone's dropped a
whole load of garbage in the ocean
but this apparent chaos is packed with
clues about the Lost World of the
ancient
Greeks this is uh really fantastic for
an
archaeologist exploring such a deep and
complex site is
[Music]
challenging diving at 45 M has several
constraints and time is one of
them the maximum we can stay per days 20
minutes it's almost impossible to work
effectively at such
depths so the team explores the site
using a technique called
photogrammetry taking hundreds of
pictures of the wreck from different
angles so instead of trying to make
decisions at 45 M where your brain
doesn't work properly take taking the
pictures allows us to have the luxury of
diving through the screen of our
computer as long as we
wanted using the unique photogrametry
data it's possible for the first time to
drain the
Mediterranean allowing sunshine to
illuminate a sight that's been in
darkness for 2 and 12,000
years
the debris lies in the shape of a
ship much of the Timber Hull has rotted
away leaving only its ancient
cargo hundreds of Earth andwar jars
known as aery piled neatly on top of
each other many of them still
intact
amrey look very odd they look very
ungainly and not very welld designed to
be storage jars or certainly container
jars on a sea vessel but they are a
design that's involved over centuries
and actually if you stack them all
really neatly together they do all make
sense and they were the way that you
transported things around the ancient
world erey like this give the
archaeologists some vital Clues
their distinctive shape varies depending
on where and when they were
made this one dates from the 4th Century
BC and comes from the Greek island of
kios 500 mil from the Rec
site so what was in
it although the aery are all now empty
they offer intriguing clues about what
they once
contained in this case we have the
opportunity to see
evidence this dark coating inside the
Anora we have to imagine that it was all
over the inside walls and it was peit or
resin so it was a kind of sealant to
make this walls waterproof so we are
sure that these are Kean wine
containers wine from the island of kios
is highly prized throughout the the
ancient
Mediterranean the wrecked ship is loaded
with the equivalent of more than 10,000
modernized bottles a hugely valuable
cargo and a telling insight into the
ancient Greek trade in luxury
goods the Greeks loved their
wine this little rack off Cyprus is the
tip of the iceberg of the wine trade it
was an absolutely fundamental part of
their society and of all their cultural
experiences whether that be religious or
whether it be letting their hair down
and having really good time the greatest
thing about ancient Greeks is their love
for life they like to talk to think to
discuss to drink to party there was a
great profit to be made in making sure
that the rich around the Mediterranean
world had a good supply of very good
wine to drink
trading in wine and other luxury items
makes good money for the Greek city
states but their ships carry an even
more precious cargo as they Traverse the
Mediterranean and Beyond from Egypt to
Southern France they spread Greek ideas
and culture that influence Western
Civilization to the present
day but this cargo never reaches its
destination
one of the most important questions that
we ask in ship Archaeology is why this
ship
sunk the biggest clue is the shape of
the
debris the way that the jars lie grouped
together rather than scattered about
proves that the vessel didn't
capsize so what did
happen the ships in Antiquity were open
decked the hold was not covered with a
deck so when the waves were very high or
we have a storm then the water was
coming
in the ship is most likely overwhelmed
by a
wave pulled down by the weight of all
the expensive wine to a watery
grave
[Music]
as the Waters of the Mediterranean
continue to drain
away they uncover unique evidence of a
Titanic clash between two ancient
superpowers this is the sight of a
battle that would change the course of
history when they saw the Romans in
front of them they had one of these oh
no
moments what can these bizarre objects
on the seabed tell us about the
merciless rise of the
Romans the 3r century BC Rome already
controls Mainland Italy and has
Ambitions to EXP band across the whole
Mediterranean but its Navy is weak Rome
was known as being a terrestrial power
not a maritime power it was not known
for fighting sea battles but they were
set on a militaristic path of Maritime
control this brings them into conflict
with another superpower of the
Mediterranean the
carthaginians the carthaginians were
great Traders great seafarers
controlling most of the West and Central
Central Mediterranean and it was that
fact that brought them into conflict
with
Rome Carthage from its position on the
North coast of Africa commands the most
powerful navy in the
region to challenge Carthage Rome must
first learn a new kind of Naval
Warfare so begins a Titanic struggle
that will last for more than a 100 years
the winner will dominate the
Mediterranean for the next seven
centuries its first truly decisive
encounter happens somewhere off the west
coast of
Sicily near the egod
islands here according to ancient
historian polius the mighty navies of
Rome and Carthage go head-to-head in an
epic
battle
he describes the Clash of two huge
fleets involving 400 ships and at least
a 100,000
men turning the Waters of the
Mediterranean blood
red but polius writes his history at
least half a century after the battle
and for a Roman audience so how reliable
is his account
however huge this battle may have been
no one has ever been able to find any
trace of it taking the description uh
from an ancient historian and actually
pointing to the exact place on the
surface of the globe where the battle
took place is extremely
difficult Bill Murray and a team of
marine archaeologists are on the trail
of some extraordinary finds reported by
local
fishermen
but the area they need to survey is huge
many miles
across so first they sonar scan the
seabed then they launch a remotely
operated vehicle to investigate the
finds
stand as you're watching the live feed
of the video from the ROV and is going
across the seafloor the the shapes
suddenly pop into view and it's
incredibly distinctive so there's a
great moment of excitement as these
objects are first
seen they discover a truly astonishing
shape 300 ft down
yeah these are the rarest artifacts we
have from
Antiquity so what is it
using the data gathered by the
Expedition it's possible to pull the
plug on the Mediterranean emptying the
waters from around the coast of Sicily
the mysterious object on the seabed
comes clearly into view it's 3 ft wide
and made of metal its Jagged edges
suggest a deadly purpose so these are
bronze battering ramps they would have
been attached to the the front of a ship
and this was the main method of
attacking and destroying ships in
Antiquity Rams are the super weapons of
ancient Naval
Warfare the large vertical fin is like a
splitting axe and the horizontal fins
are like blades to slice through an
enemy ship's
Timbers you didn't have cannon fire
there were no kind of guns Al Pirates of
the Caribbean or anything like that
the only way to take down an enemy ship
was to smash a massive hole in the
middle of it and let it sink to the
bottom and the only way of doing that
was to Ram
it a closer look reveals that this Ram
is battle damaged its metal edges broken
and distorted by a violent
Collision in one episode we're told that
the men up in a forward Tower were
literally catapulted out of the Tower
and into the sea after a ram
strike and we're told that it was an
effective Ram strike because as the
ancient author wrote bronze hit
bronze and this isn't the only Discovery
all
right Based on data from the survey
draining way more of the Mediterranean
reveals a remarkable pattern 10 more
Rams scattered across 2 square
miles more than enough to convince
historians that an important naval
battle took place
here but is it the legendary Battle of
the egod islands described by
polius an unlikely piece of evidence May
hold the
answer a single AER storage jar found
near one of the
Rams by analyzing its shape
archaeologists can narrow down when and
where it was
made it's like finding a black box
recorder the team believes the AA is
carthaginian and dates to the 3r century
BC the same period as the battle of the
egod
islands the historian polius describes
how the carthaginians are carrying
supplies for their soldiers in
Sicily could this Emperor be part of
that
cargo the plan was to cross to mount
ariche unobserved by the enemy and
offload the stores then take on the
soldiers in the lighten ships and engage
the
enemy
but the carthaginians never make it
compelling evidence from the drained
seabed now indicates this is where it
all happened a number of rams line up
and give us a bearing that makes some
sense and that's fascinating that is
exciting the words of an ancient
historian and the evidence of modern
technology both point to the same
conclusion this is the s
of the battle of the egod
islands it was an important enough event
for the Romans that they remembered the
date it was actually written down in a
calendar somewhere and we know that it
occurred on 10 March 241
BC this is not your typical naval battle
where both sides prepare this was a
battle of
opportunity the carthaginians still
Laden with supplies head for Shore
believing the coast is
clear but the Romans keep dozens of
their ships hidden behind one of the
islands it's a huge
Ambush the Lookouts spied The
carthaginian Ships coming in and as the
carthaginians saw the Romans in front of
them they had one of these oh no
moments so we're talking about tens of
thousands of men on board these ships
and they would have lined up across from
each other in lines of battle headed
toward each other at a great rate and
smashed into each other
head-to-head polius describes what
happened
next before long they were
defeated 50 of the carthaginian ships
were s
and 70 captured with their Crews while
the prisoners numbered almost
10,000 another discovery on the seabed
is a stark reminder that this epic
Victory came at a high price in human
[Music]
life this is the last resting place of
thousands of brave
men
and it has been judged so important that
its exact location must remain
secret there's nothing else really like
this it's the first ancient battle site
that's ever been discovered it's just an
incredible debris
field but the battle of the aad islands
was the turning point when a Roman Fleet
managed to absolutely trance a
carthaginian fleet at
Sea this was the defining battle where r
went from a regional power to a
superpower the struggle between Rome and
Carthage would last for another
Century but Victory here set Rome on a
path to shaping the destiny of Europe
for the next 700
years as the last of its water runs away
the Mediterranean reveals a final secret
what can draining the Bay of Naples
teach teach us about the glory and the
decadence of the Roman
Empire 2,000 years ago Rome has grown
far beyond its Italian Homeland its
Legions control a vast area from North
Africa to Northern Europe from Spain to
the Black Sea and the Roman Navy
dominates the medit anean from its Port
next to the city of bay in the shadow of
Mighty
Vesuvius Bay earns a reputation as the
Sin City of ancient Rome it's famous for
debauchery and
excess but what really went on in this
Seaside party town and why does so much
of it lie aand abandoned beneath the
waves now Marine archaeologist John
Henderson is exploring the secrets of
this sunken
city starting with the huge Harbor walls
that once surrounded the city's
Port these are built by the
Romans they were incredible Engineers
you can still see the artificial
Construction of this very clearly you
can see the brick work overlapping
bricks
[Music]
amazing beyond the port walls lie
magnificent Villas where Roman emperors
host lavish
parties look at this this is a mosaic
floor of one of the bath
houses looks like it was just done
yesterday it's phenomenal
absolutely
[Music]
amazing this is called the inum It's
actually an elaborate dining room for
the emperor Claudius you can imagine
people eating food surrounded by these
water nms it was built to entertain the
emperor's most honored
guests well one of the things I'm
interested in is actually the scale of
the site much of the focus has been on
the resort area of itself but on the
margins of the site there are constantly
new areas coming
up that's it slow it
down there's a lot down
there so why did the Romans lavish so
much wealth on building a pleasure City
here the Romans came to Bay ey because
of the lovely Marat time climate and the
thermal Springs but B was also a very
important port it's a natural Port one
of the best ports on the western coast
of Italy at the
time wealth brought pleasure and exess
to this Las Vegas of the Roman
World there were parties there was
drinking it was a place to get
prostitutes and writers at the time
refer to it as a harbor of Vice or a a
Vortex of
luxury the famous Ro philosopher senica
is appalled by what he
finds by ey is a place to be
avoided people wandering drunk along the
beach the riotous reveling of sailing
parties the Lakes noisy with
singing but time is running out for this
party
[Music]
town gradually many of its most
impressive public buildings and private
Villas are lost beneath the
[Music]
waves what
happened based on detailed sonar
scanning draining away the Mediterranean
begins to reveal the real story of the
rise and fall of
bay it exposes just how much of the city
fell under the waves
430 Acres of streets shops warehouses
and luxury
villas draining beyond the town uncovers
The
reason an extraordinary landscape shaped
by powerful underground
forces the whole town sits inside the
shallow Crater of a giant
volcano you hear about Naples people
talk about Bas they don't seem to
realize realiz that the whole Western
Bay of Naples itself is a massive
volcano we're actually standing in a
volcano
now the people of bay may not understand
the unpredictable forces stirring
beneath
them and we know we're sat on a
volcano but it's not your normal volcano
it's this much larger a much more
complex volcanic
system there's remarkable evidence of a
Restless power 3 mil away across the bay
in the temple of
carapus it's really when you get into
the Roman ruins that you can see what's
going on you have to look closely though
if you look up at the column behind me
you'll see in the middle part it's got
this strange texture to it lots and lots
of holes in
it there's even bits of shell on this
this is a stone boring Marine mollusk
that tells me that this stuff has been
under Under the
Sea time enough for those molus to get
to grips with the columns but look now
these columns are in place and look
where those marker Horizons are now
that's like a tide on the side of a bath
telling you where the sea level was so
we know that this has been dropped under
the sea and it's now risen above can
draining the Waters of the bay even
further explain why this ancient
landscape is constantly rising and
falling
and finally show why the Romans lost
their Sin
City B once a major Roman
Port lies half
submerged amid a volcanic
landscape John Henderson has been
exploring the area beneath the waves
and he finds a Telltale sign of the
power at work here so we've got all
these bubbles are coming out of the
ground all this hot air coming up from
the
seabed you really get a sense here of
the power that's
underneath waiting to burst
out hot water piling out of the ground
under the
sea and I've never seen anything like
this these underwater vents are
superheated by molten rock from the
volcano below evidence that the forces
stirring under by ey are highly
active locals call the area compy fgi
the fields of
fire now for the first time draining the
water from the entire Bay exposes an
extraordinary sight
24 separate volcanoes nesting inside the
crater it spans an incredible 38 square
miles but geologists here have been
mapping deep inside the Earth
itself now draining not only the
Mediterranean but looking deep into the
layers of rock below it reveals a
fantastic iCal sight giant cauldrons of
superheated molten rock known as magma
chambers that slowly empty and fill over
centuries evidence that this huge
volcanic system is still very much alive
basically you've got magma Chambers
sitting under the sea which operate
almost like Bellow when they fill full
of lava the ground goes up and then when
they empty again the ground goes down
and this process is going on
constantly it's as if the land within
the can't be fgre crater itself is
breathing you feel like you're standing
on some kind of Giant's
chest you feel minute compared to the
giant tectonic forces that are creating
the world around you the damage caused
by these breathing chambers of magma
coincides with the decline of the Roman
Empire
fire as part of the city slides beneath
the Mediterranean the population shrinks
and the party's
end Sin
City is no
more today the scientists studying the
landscape here believe that pressures in
the magma Chambers are increasing once
again and that could have catastrophic
consequences for the millions of people
living close by we know it's an active
system so one of the interesting
problems we have with something the size
of campy flag gr is is it going to erupt
big or is it going to erupt
small big could me very
big in
ad79 nearby Vesuvius
erupts it destroys the city of
Pompei thousands of people burn to death
or choke on volcanic
ash but scientists know the volcanic
system feeding the fields of fire is far
larger and far more powerful than
Vesuvius and with so many people living
nearby it's vital to keep a close eye on
the breathing giant beneath
them it's even more critical that we
monitor volcanoes like this and that's
because we're verging on the side of
what we call a super volcano even the
smallest changes in the ground level or
its temperature could be a vital warning
sign that the Unstoppable forces of
nature are about to turn
ugly if we had an eruption where these
multiple craters evacuated it would be
devastating it would essentially flatten
this
area the eruption could be almost 10
times more powerful than the one at
Santorini that shattered the minoan
world vast amounts of volcanic material
would be ejected into the atmosphere
blocking out the
sunlight global temperatures would
plummet with devastating
consequences
new scanning technology reveals
remarkable evidence lying hidden beneath
the Waters of the Mediterranean the raw
forces of nature still shaping this
volcanic
landscape Priceless evidence of the
trade that drove the ancient
world and an epic
battle that changed the course of
history
[Applause]
lost
civilizations mysterious sunken cities
and legendary Atlantis
itself vanished beneath the waves there
is a huge amount of unrecorded human
history beneath the ocean surface that
we don't know very much about at
all imagine if we could empty the
oceans letting the water drain away to
reveal the secrets of the seaf
fluid now we
can using the latest underwater
technology piercing the Deep oceans and
turning accurate data into 3D
images is this a huge underwater temple
carved by a mysterious Lost
Civilization why are these perfectly
circular Stones lying at the bottom of a
bay in the aan sea they all shapes on
the seabed that just don't make sense
are these just rocks or the remains of
an ancient city parts of this are just
beginning to be revealed for the first
time
wow and is the real sight of Atlantis
finally about to be revealed people want
to believe in places like Atlantis they
want to believe in other
worlds
stories of sunken cities have fascinated
for
Millennia the most tantalizing of
all at
Atlantis first described by ancient
philosopher
Plato a dazzling civilization destroyed
by the gods as punishment for human
[Music]
Pride
people connect to that story and it's
because of this idea of an ancient
civilization a Utopia that we've evolved
from 2,000 years later the idea of
Atlantis continues to Fascinate A-list
archaeologists and the producers of
b-list movies Atlantis is the story of
those who like today would use the
marvels of science to conquer and
enslave Atlant
a world that worshiped strange gods of
science a science gone berserk in would
have loved this okay he would have had a
great time he would have said at last
you know people are listening to me
people are taking my story seriously and
he would have he would have enjoyed this
immensely using science not science
fiction draining the oceans exposes new
evidence about Atlantis and Other
Stories of great sunken cities around
the
world as the waters seed from around the
remote Japanese island of
yonaguni a mysterious formation begins
to
appear could it be the creation of an
advanced ancient
[Music]
people janoni lies in the East China
Sea
the waters here are
perilous schools of hammerhead sharks
Patrol amid powerful
currents typhoons frequently batter the
island for divers it's the ultimate
challenge kiiro arataki is one of the
pioneers of diving
[Music]
here the water was crystal clear I felt
as if I were looking down into the
seabed from the
sky searching for a new dive site he
makes a startling
discovery
I saw a steplike formation like Terrace
Fields I thought for a moment it was
similar to The Mach
WIS so I named The Spot the submarine
ruins it's an extraordinary
spectacle
the size of five football
[Music]
fields smooth sided walls rise up to the
summit the height of an eight-story
building flights of stone steps climb up
from the
base and on every side the shapes and
forms are strikingly
regular it can't be formed naturally
without human involvement it couldn't be
like
that so what could it
be it's impossible to investigate the
structure fully by
diving the only way is to conduct a
survey using the latest scanning
technology although the shallow Waters
around Yuni Island are close to human
habitation we don't know much about
them it's an unknown
Frontier using Sonar scans hironobu can
records Recs a complete digital map of
the
seafloor using this data it's possible
for the very first time to drain away
the waters and reveal What Lies Beneath
an exact
detail the summit of the mysterious
structure begins to
appear
water pours off its smooth Terrace
layers exposing them once again to the
sky and with the monument left high and
dry its true scale becomes
clear fast imposing and
spectacular
the incredible Discovery attracts
worldwide
attention divers journalists and TV
Crews flock to
yonaguni all asking what could this
mysterious structure
be and scientists come here too among
them is Professor masaki Kimura one of
Japan's top Marine geologists my
when I dived underwater to explore it I
felt right away that it must be a
man-made
structure he finds several features that
he believes indicate human
activity here you will see something
that looks like the front gate of a
castle that's like like a tunnel and you
go through
it on the far side of the tunnel a road
loops around to a flight of steps
watched over by two mysterious Stone
objects they are mound likee bges here
and here and if you look at them you
will find turtles with their necks
extended on both sides according to
ancient Japanese folklore the dragon God
ryujin lives in an underwater Palace
watched over by
Turtles to Professor Kimura this
indicates that the monument is so
important it needs
guarding and that's not
all if you go up this path you get to
this place this portion is triangular
that's why it's called the triangle pool
since this fairy big and shallow as well
you can relax in
it also the sea surface is very close to
it and it's warm due to the sunlight you
feel chilly after you come out of the
deeper area down there and you can warm
up
here but The Monument's most striking
feature is its wide flat Terraces large
enough to support thousands of
people Professor Kim believes the
Gateway stairs Turtles and Terraces all
Point towards one
[Music]
purpose judging from its shape I think
they used it as a
castle but to prove his theory Professor
Kimura needs more the artifacts of those
who once lived
here he scour the structure looking for
Clues and discovers what looks like
primitive
tools then hidden behind one of the
Great Walls the most remarkable find of
[Music]
all look at this a symbol is inscribed
here and here's a hole probably they
hung this article like this and here's
something looking like a letter maybe it
could be a kind of Talisman to protect
people from Evil for Professor Kimura
the case is closed the artifacts and The
Monument's regular shapes prove that
humans lived here 8,000 years ago after
that rising sea levels claim the
territory of this lost race of Master
Builders but is that the real story of
janoni Professor Kimura believes that
this extraordinary structure off the
coast of Japan is a gigantic castle
built long before the pyramids of Egypt
by a mysterious Lost
Civilization but is
it with the water drained away it's
possible to scrutinize the monument in
forensic
detail the edges appear regular and
straight as if made from blocks carved
by human
hand but closer examination reveals
something else the surfaces are smooth
and
unbroken the monument is not assembled
from handmade blocks but is in fact one
solid mass of
Rock
the pyramid area and the headline behind
it are connected with each other the
surface of the terrain has a lot of
groves so you may think they're separate
but since they consist of the identical
Stone they are originally
connected the basic form of the monument
is clearly
natural but what about the Gateway steps
Turtles and
pool could it be that an ancient people
carved into this huge Rock transforming
it into a great Castle or
Temple studying the Headland on Shore
provides the
answer the shapes here are strikingly
similar to those found on the monument
and that's because they were formed in
exactly the same way both are made of
sandstone which when subjected to stress
such as during an earthquake can
fracture along vertical faults forming
angular shapes and what look like Steps
put something like that underwater have
the water wash over the top of it and
clear away all the debris uh and you've
got very very fine step-like structures
but they're no more human-made than any
other uh structure down there the lack
of tool marks is further confirmation
the forces which shaped this remark able
place are
geological but what of the artifacts
perhaps the monument if not built by
ancient people was inhabited by them
walking these steps crowding these
natural
Terraces but so far no other objects
have been found suggesting that the
Talisman and tools were dropped from a
boat passing overhead landing on the
monument simply by
Chance the clear thing for yonaguni for
me is there's no Pottery there's no
evidence of actual human occupation
there's not a single wall from the site
there there's nothing on it that
indicates human
activity the Yanagi Monument is an
extraordinary natural formation created
by epic geological
forces but its shapes appear so regular
that many still believe it holds a
secret ancient
purpose you can take that leap if you
have an imagination and say yes this
could be an ancient city Beneath the Sea
but in the case of Yanagi I'm in those
ranks that feel that it's not it's
geology we want to believe that science
doesn't have all the answers we want to
believe innately that there is something
out there that we can connect with
spiritually and that hasn't really been
polluted by being the subject of
scientific
discovery and still among the Believers
is Professor
Kimura he remains convinced that the
monument was inhabited by his ancestors
and continues to search for evidence to
prove the doubters
[Music]
wrong beneath the oceans of the world
lie many more tantalizing traces of
possible lost
civilizations as the water continues to
drain away in the Eastern
Mediterranean astonishing structures
emerge in a quiet Island
Harbor is this jumble of shaped Stones
the architectural debris of a once great
City alikanas Bay a tourist hotspot on
the island of zakinthos
Greece diver pavlos Vos sets out to take
some underwater
photos I went in the water to make
photographs General photographs of face
of weed of things in the bottom rocks
formations
things
Pavlo swims farther out into the bay in
search of clearer
water then out of the Gloom he sees
something that will change his
life it was really
strange they don't look like the rocks
at the harbor or the rocks at the
beachs it's something really unique
because it looks like
man-made the debris stretches out for
hundreds of yards in all
directions the area is so large that
pavlos is convinced he's found the
remains of an entire
town there are too many the different
shaped
Stones they look like pavement or like
walls that have fallen down and break in
pieces but definitely they don't look
natural but I was dreaming of Palace and
temples and unseen
life it was an an amazing
find the discovery sends a bolt of
electricity through the world of
archaeology Professor Michael stamatakis
immediately travels to zakinthos to
investigate when they sent me initially
some photographs I have to say that I
was confused and I thought that they
probably are some man-made
products
stamatakis recalls seeing similar shapes
on land at the sight of an ancient
settlement built over 2,000 years
ago you see the The Carving
here looks
like and also the other so we have some
finding alas in this size small
one but long and narrow
if the same shapes lie on the seabed
they could indicate an ancient
settlement just offshore concealed under
the bay and forgotten about for
centuries if you saw in in any scientist
this Photograph and also a photograph of
malikana say that's the same they say
Okay comparing the images is not
enough
the only way to reveal a complete
picture of the structures is a detailed
underwater
survey Simon Brown is an expert in 3D
modeling but the task facing him is
immense right now we're not quite sure
how big the area is I've estimated it's
about 16 Acres which will be more than
double the largest subject I've ever
covered to
date
it's a weird place there's definitely
features here that I've never seen
anywhere else
before they look out of
place but then I started to see more
regular shapes that look like cut stone
so my mind then starts to think is it
is it
manmade can draining the Waters of the
Mediterranean provide the
answer Simon Brown is mapping mysterious
underwater structures discovered in a
Greek Bay could they be the remains of
an ancient
town he takes nearly 4,000
highresolution photographs of of the
seafloor tracking each with pinpoint
accuracy through
GPS using these images it's now possible
to do something which has never been
done before drain the Waters of alakus
bay and reveal for the first time ever a
3D plan of the entire seaf
Flor as the Mediterranean begins to
recede a world is exposed that's been
invisible for thousands of
years first the rocky Shoreline is left
high and
dry then from the dark depths regular
shapes begin to appear hidden among the
rocks could they be the bases of stone
columns which together one once formed a
grand
colonade the use of colonades is a
turning point in ancient Greek
architecture Builders can now switch
from wood to Stone a far stronger
material to create ever larger temples
to the
gods a colonade in Alanis Bay would
prove that an important ancient
settlement once stood here but some
experts
remain skeptical there are structures
all over the world that mimic something
that humans may have created doesn't
mean that humans created
them with the water drained away it's
now possible to search the seabed for
evidence of human
occupation fragments of the pots people
cooked
with charcoal from their fires tools for
farming and weapons for defending their
homes any objects made of metal clay or
stone should have
[Music]
survived but there's
nothing which means these extraordinary
remains whatever they are are not the
relics of a lost
town so what are
[Music]
they the first approach was to see the
material not only from pictures but to
touch
it it's very soft it's not easy to to
assume you can make a building with this
very soft material the so-called bases
of the columns are composed of this soft
material so this material is just a
little hardened mud is nothing more it's
like the material we have in the
cliff further analysis reveals the
formations are what geologists call
concretions solid blocks of sedimentary
rock formed by powerful volcanic
activity underwater vents release
methane from deep within the Earth
combining with microbes and sediment the
methane causes regular circular shapes
to form far from being a relic of
ancient Greece the structures here
predate human activities by 5 million
years
despite all the evidence against his
theory havos Vos remains convinced that
the Fantastical landscape he discovered
was shaped by his ancestors I don't know
if there was a palace castle some
temples storages or just houses this is
for the scientist to find what I see is
signs of civilization
classical civilizations dominate the
Mediterranean for over a thousand years
today all around its Coast people tell
stories of sunken
cities as the waters around Greece drain
away further an extraordinary underwater
Vista is
exposed could these patterns on the sea
floor be remnants of an ancient
city
the village of alonesos sits on a small
island just off the Greek
Coast at first glance an ordinary
fishing
port but in
1967 less than a 100 yard out to sea
something attracts the attention of a
visiting Maritime
archaeologist snorkeling in 13 ft of
water Nicholas Fleming catches a glimpse
of regular shapes on the
seafloor then exploring deeper he sees
what he thinks is evidence of human
activity I looked at these rows of
stones and I I just had no idea what it
was but I realized immediately uh that
it was man-made that we were looking at
a large part of a town and I mean I was
just went crazy Fleming is convinced he
has found something special but could
these simply be natural formations
mimicking human structures like the
concretions of nearby alanus Bay the
following year Fleming returns with a
team of surveyors to discover the
truth using tape measures they document
what they find and the results are
astonishing
the site is strewn with signs of human
activity pots storage vessels and tools
lie across a huge area of the
seabed there can be no doubt Fleming has
discovered the remains of an ancient
town it's named Pavo Petri after a
nearby
Island but who built it and
when okay check all that these questions
inspire ire a generation of
archaeologists well I've always been
interested in submersed settlements um
submersed towns and I'd read about paet
as a boy and this idea of an intact
prehistoric Town underwater just seemed
you know incredibly romantic incredibly
exciting Henderson can now fulfill a
childhood dream and explore this haunted
underwater world for himself and here we
have a have a qun stone here you can see
it's got a very
concave concave surface there that's for
grinding ground whatever it was that you
were turning into you know
flower that's quite a clear after fact
very
nice there is a huge AER one AER two AER
three four five this gives you a real
example of what's coming out of the sand
what's eroding out of the sand look
that's the base of an
Afra there's the AA shape there it's on
its side there's another one next to it
and another one
there and further into the bay more
evidence of human life and
death so here's assist
grave Edge set slabs
a very small
one possibly for a
baby there are about 40 of these on the
[Music]
site diving gives intriguing glimpses of
objects lying upon the
seabed but it's impossible to gain a
complete
picture to do this it must be mapped
with a latest in underwater scanning
technology using this data it's now
possible to drain away the waters above
Pavo Petri and bring sunlight back to a
forgotten world world and a true sunken
city with the entire Bay drained away
everything becomes
clear the lines are the foundations of
buildings laid out in clear
streets at the heart of the town is a
large open area
perhaps an ancient
marketplace and nearby the remnants of a
huge structure perhaps an important
Civic
building the remains covered 20 acres
and the town could have housed 4,000
people a thriving ancient settlement
once existed here the the next challenge
is to discover who built it and
when we know how old the occupation of
the site is because we've got pottery
and and pottery particularly in this
part of the world is very well
dated what was really exciting is we
actually found evidence repter from the
end of the Stone
Age so we've actually got occupation
here from about 5,500 years ago and then
we've got every single bit of poy you
would expect up about 1,100 BC there's
no gaps in that so the place seems to
have been continuously occupied
throughout the Bronze
Age paavo Petri was occupied for 2400
years during a revolutionary period of
human
development at its peak in the Bronze
Age around 1700 BC it looked like
this a perfect example of the time when
Europeans start to live in stone-built
towns
with regular laid out
streets but one question
remains why did the Builders of this
town choose this particular location in
a remote part of ancient
Greece exploring the drained landscape
around the ancient city reveals an all
important
clue at its Edge a huge sandbank
stretches out into the ocean during the
Bron's age people don't build ports out
of stone they bring ships up to the
shore and then Beach them and Pavo
petry's location means it can exploit
the trade routes that boom during the
Bronze Age across the
Mediterranean evidence of early
commercial activity is everywhere the
interesting thing is we've clearly got a
lot of material coming in we've found
thousands and thousands of sharffs a
very large storage vessel which have
been used for storing um olive oil wine
that kind of thing and generally
anything they were like the containers
of the
day and that's not all Pavo Petri is
also a hub for
manufacturing we've got a lot of
evidence for um Loom weights thousands
of loom weights way more than you would
need for domestic production so it seems
that maybe textiles were something that
were being produced on the site and
perhaps
exported
paavo Petri is an extraordinary bustling
vibrant Port City and an important
center of
trade so how did such an advanced
Metropolis meet its
end an ancient submerged City off the
coast of Greece how it came to lie on
the seaf Flor is a mystery one of the
interesting things about paavo petti and
its submergence there's actually no
historical references to it at all it
sunk under the waves and then it was out
of sight out of mind and there's
certainly no classical sources that
refer to it sinking and there's nothing
until its Discovery really in the 20th
century scanning the drained Bay could
reveal what happened to pava
Petri at the edge of the town it's
possible to make out three mysterious
lines these are strips of beach rock
formed by the action of sunlight on
saltwater they form only near the
shoreline it can mean only one thing
earthquakes caused this land to subside
into the
sea so there was a big earthquake
perhaps part part of the remains went
under the water and part of them were
still surviving then there was another
earthquake it was pushed under then
there was a third and it was
gone pav La Petri is one of the most
most important Bronze Age sites in the
world and the oldest submerged Town ever
discovered but it's not
[Music]
alone a lot of the major finds in the
next couple of decades are going to come
from the sea I think we have the
potential to to to rewrite what we know
about human history
pava Petri is an extraordinary find but
it is not the legendary
Atlantis various locations for Plato's
dazzling City have been proposed around
the world but most academic
investigations point to one place the
Mediterranean as its Waters continue to
drain away at its Western end new and
tense analizing evidence is revealed
could archaeologists finally have found
the sight of Plato's famous lost
city Mark gutcher is a geophysicist long
fascinated by Plato's story I do think
that becoming interested in Atlantis can
be almost like a a bug or an infection
or or like gambling I think one can
become obsessed
Plato wrote about Atlantis in 360 BC
describing an advanced Metropolis 9,000
years before his own time lost beneath
the waves in a cataclysmic
event Mark gutcher has analyzed Plato's
text searching for Clues to its location
this power came forth out of the
Atlantic Ocean from an island situated
in front of The Straits which are by you
called the pillars of
Heracles the pillars of Heracles is the
name given by PLO to the maritime
boundary of the ancient Greek World many
locations have been suggested but Mark
believes he has the answer the Straits
of Gibralter so here at capes spartel
we're at the northern edge of the
Moroccan Atlantic coast and just at the
entrance to the Straits of jalter about
10 to 15 km off to the Northwest there's
a submerged Bank some people have
suggested that it might have been
inhabited and it might have formed the
origin of the Atlantis
Legend today this area sits under the
second busiest shipping route in the
world a difficult place for subsea
investigation during a project to study
rising sea levels here Mark gets his
chance
using a remotely operated vehicle or ROV
he sets out to map the
seafloor it's challenging
work it was very difficult both the
towing of the camera was difficult
keeping the ship in place was difficult
and especially trying to keep the ROV in
place was really really
difficult finally Mark gets the sonar
scanning data that he
needs now combining this information
with the latest computer Graphics it's
possible to drain away the seawater from
between the ancient pillars of Heracles
and attempt to solve one of the greatest
archaeological mysteries of all
time soon rocks begin to emerge and the
unmistakable outline of an island
gradually
appears is this the site of Atlantis
exposed for the first time in 11,000
years once again important Clues lie in
Plato's own writing Plato says that the
city and all of its warlike men were
destroyed in one day and night of
terrible misfortune caused by strong
earthquakes and
floods the Island revealed by draining
the ocean sits on a subduction zone a
boundary between the huge tectonic
plates that make up the Earth's surface
the exact point where the biggest
earthquakes
strike a a series of powerful
earthquakes and tsunamis could have
obliterated Atlantis and sent the island
on which it rests down into the ocean
depths you could imagine that during
great earthquakes there might have been
some subsidence so if we were to take
into account maybe 20 or 30 meters of
subsidence due to those earthquakes uh
there might have been a somewhat larger
Island there the geology supports
Plato's account of the destruction of
Atlantis but one other vital piece of
evidence is still
needed draining the ocean has revealed a
mysterious island exactly where Plato
said Atlantis would be but one other
piece of evidence must be present for it
actually to be Atlantis the remains of
substantial man-made structures using
the drained landscape
it's possible to study the Island's
surface in extraordinary
three-dimensional
detail searching carefully for the
remains of walls temples Bridges and
anything constructed by human
hands but there are none nowhere on this
Mysterious Island are there any lines or
geometric shapes which would indicate
the presence of a great ancient city
Atlantis did not exist in the the tiny
island of spartel if it did exist traces
of it have not yet been
found however the story of this
submerged island is not over yet there
may be no trace of a City built out of
stone but evidence found on land nearby
suggests that during the Stone Age when
sea levels were much lower people did
live here and in many other places just
like it and during this period our human
ancestors make some of the most
important breakthroughs of all time they
learn how to farm keep domesticated
animals use sophisticated tools build
wooden houses and begin to
trade then the last ice age comes to an
[Music]
end over the course of 15,000 years sea
levels rise by 400
ft and the territory of these early
people
vanishes their tools homes and weapons
are washed
away that Elemental human story may help
explain the Timeless appeal of the
Atlantis Legend there are many many
stories out there in the world that
recall times when land that was once
inhabited was submerged did that
information inform Plato's fiction about
Atlantis I think there's no doubt that
almost every culture in the world has a
flood myth a delude story because we
developed as a species within this
period of rising sea level so that for
me is so fundamental to understanding
ourselves as a species that we should be
looking into
this Plato's story of Atlantis is about
human Folly and the destructive power of
nature today the rising level of the
oceans threatens all Coastal
communities great port cities like
Bangkok hoi Min City and Daka are all at
risk and in North America there's one of
particular concern
New
Orleans sitting on the banks of the
great Mississippi River the city's
average height is 6 ft below sea level
this makes it highly vulnerable to
flooding in 2005 disaster
strikes Hurricane Katrina causes a
massive storm surge and the levies
designed to protect the city are
breached
the resulting floods are catastrophic
nearly 2,000 people die and many more
are left homeless and the situation in
New Orleans is getting worse because the
city itself is
sinking due in part to the removal of
groundwater some districts of New
Orleans are subsiding by 2 in a year
given ongoing sea level rise which is a
scientific fact the time will come when
some of our settlements in our time are
underwater cities like New Orleans they
all have suffered incursions of water
and the time will come when we will no
longer be able to battle that
incursion by the turn of the next
Century New Orleans could be
uninhabitable a mysterious underwater
city studied by Maritime
archaeologists
a modern day
Atlantis treasure hunting has captured
our imaginations for centuries I think
everybody at some point in their life
has dreamed about finding treasure on
you straight away that it was gold there
was over 30 tons of silver ingots on
board 200,000 coins gold emeralds once
treasure and treasure diving gets in
your blood it's hard to get it out
Sunken Treasures remain lost below the
waves until
now imagine if we could empty the oceans
draining the water away to reveal the
secrets of the
sea now we
can using the latest underwater scanning
technology piercing the Deep oceans and
turning accurate data into 3D
images how do you excavate a fortune in
sunken silver from a wreck lost in
shifting Sands it's an amazing amazing
amount of
money why is the treasure from a wrecked
Spanish gallion spread over 10 miles of
Florida seabed and how can the world's
biggest Hall of lost gold bullion be
recovered from the Arctic
[Applause]
depths
today moving money is simple these days
you push a button and funds are
electronically
transferred but in the past the oceans
were pretty consistent means of moving
the world's
money for centuries treasure ships
sailed the oceans of the world packed
with silver gold and precious stones
hunted by Pirates battered by
storms threatened by reefs and rocky
shores the reason that you would find
treasure underwater is the water has
been the greatest Highway in human
history and where there's treasure there
are treasure
Hunters I think people certainly catch
Gold
Fever I think people love searching for
things it's deep in our
psyche around the world hundreds of
treasure wrecks remain
unexplored as the Waters of the oceans
begin to drain away they reveal their
most valuable
Secrets the English Channel 5 miles off
the coast of
Kent the grave of an 18th century
merchant
ship lost to the waves and carrying a
fortune in
silver the Priceless wreck often
vanishes and reappears under ever
shifting
sandbags can draining away the English
Channel reveal the wreck and the sunken
treasure January 8th
1740 the Dutch East India Company ship
the rosev sets off from the Netherlands
into the English Channel it's on an
8-month long Voyage to Indonesia then
known as the Dutch East Indies the
center of the spice
trade on board are Merchants soldiers
and a precious
cargo it said that there were about
300,000 gilders of silver on board of
the
ship in silver bars and about 36,000 of
coins a fortune in today's money
equivalent to around $100 million
doll a few miles off the English Coast a
violent storm blows up the ship hits
sandbanks and
disappears
237 men die and the
silver is lost to the
Sea now more than 270 years later a team
of underwater archaeologists investigate
Martine Manders heads the Expedition
it's enormously unique to do a large
kill excavation under
water we really have to take care of
what's down there under water or we lose
it forever these are treacherous
Waters to locate the wreck the team uses
the latest technology multi-beam sonar
scanning
we came out and did a multibeam survey
you create a whole a whole image of of
the
CED multi-beam sonar fires sound waves
to the sea floor the return signal
displays the shape and depth of the
features beneath that way we can start
putting that puzzle
[Music]
together combining the sonar data with
the latest visualization techniques it's
now possible to empty the Waters of the
English
Channel as the sea drains away the first
challenge the team faces is revealed the
landscape under the
surface it's an incredible Hidden
World miles of Rolling Dunes like a
desert
underwater the goodwi
Sands lying close to the surface surface
these endlessly shifting Sands are a
deadly threat to
shipping they called it the great ship
swallower it's the graveyard for around
2,000 ships each running around in the
treacherous
shallows the rose viik is swallowed here
and disappears for
centuries have the Sands shifted enough
to finally reveal this treasure
ship
as the Waters of the English Channel
continue to drain away a shape
emerges Twisted Timbers of a ship from
the 18th century to an expert eye
artifacts of Dutch
origin and as it's revealed high and dry
it's finally clear this is all that is
left of the Rose
Lake archaeologists can now now view the
remains of the ship from any angle and
examine it in fine
detail the whole shape is long lost to
the ocean but there is a pile of Timbers
collapsed deck planks lying at strange
angles and five cannons scattered
around we're basically uncovering
something that's that hasn't been seen
for the past 250
years but where is the the treasure
we're going to dive to it and
investigate it and hope to find the
secrets that this ship
reveals for a lot of people this is a
treasure ship uh for the archaeologist
this is a treasure ship because we get
so much
information fast moving Tides make the
Expedition
difficult each day there might be only
one hour between Tides that's safe for
diving it is a race against the clock
going down into an elevator is like
going back in time take it down I'll
give you an all
stop it's a time capsule of
7040 okay can relax we've got to fix
okay an umbilical cord provides air 75
ft
down it was really really exciting to
start diving there that was swimming and
then suddenly you see these cannons
appearing and wood sticking out of the
[Music]
seabed you really get this idea that
this is the place where all these people
died this is a
grave the drained wreck of the rosik
shows the scale of the
challenge debris is spread over a large
area here's what's thought to be the
main part of the ship but around 400 ft
to the Northwest lie two anchors and a
pile of
barrels and more than 900 ft to the
Northeast 10 Cannon spread
around to the east eight more cannon in
a row next to another
anchor the team has only a 12we window
to work the Rec site and it can take
days to excavate just a few Square fet
so they must Focus their
search we have to make choices and this
is what we did on the basis of uh the
milter beam
data Mar time decides to home in on the
stern it's the place where the officers
maybe the passengers where the merchant
man used to uh live during their trip
where money was
stored but how much treasure might still
be down
there using enormous vacuums to remove
the sand they hunt carefully amongst the
debris yeah I got
it Martine finds a broken chest with its
contents spilling out and then
a thrilling
moment a silver coin and soon dozens
more money destined for the East Indies
that's been lying here for more than
[Music]
years the wreck of the roseine is
beginning to reveal its
Treasures di well di
well these are pieces of eight eight
ra some people might know them from the
pirate
films the Spanish Ral was the standard
trading currency of the 18th
century made of silver a single coin is
worth more than a week's pay for a
sailor these coins are some of the
thousands that the Dutch East India
Company places on board ship all minted
just before the rose viik
sales but some of the other discovered
coins are noticeably different these are
large
ducat but they're old they're very old
these are 17th century so they're
they're probably about 70 years 80 years
older than when the ship
wrecked they're not the newly minted
company money that the ship is supposed
to be
carrying trading in private money was
banned by the Dutch East India Company
so finding these coins raises new
questions if they aren't company money
who are they and what are they used
for the drained landscape around the
rosev reveals
Clues the Ral are found in clusters in
the stern area the part of the ship
where company money is
stored but surprisingly the other coins
are found mixed in with them
some even show evidence of being kept
secret but really interesting of this
coin is this little hole maybe it's it's
it's it's worn under the clothes maybe
somebody had a collar with all all sorts
of coins and just keeping it hidden
could these coins found at the bottom of
the English Channel be incredible new
evidence of one of the oldest trades in
history
smuggling so we have a notary deed an
official document in Amsterdam Martine
Manders investigates the sunken treasure
of the rosev and meets historian matus
van rosum um and and this is the
interesting thing we had these
combinations of coins yeah all different
kinds very old that's definitely private
trade private trade means a booming
Black Market in smuggled
silver isn't that illegal it was uh
illegal because the company banned the
shipment of silver from the Republic to
Asia and back so this is evidence this
is basically all
illegal silver is worth more in the East
Indies than in the Netherlands because
it can be used to buy trade goods like
spices enterprising members of the crew
collect cash from their families and
friends then once they arrive in Asia
they simply sell their private silver to
the Dutch East India Company for a
profit it's illegal but the company
turns a blind eye to the trade because
they use the smuggled silver to buy more
spices draining the rosev reveals that
not only are the pr coins found in the
stern they're also discovered in other
areas of the
wreck this poses a new
question was it only the merant did this
or was it more widespread this was
actually very
widespread the captain the first mate
the surgeons the company Merchant on
board the ship then the lower ranks does
indicate that the whole crew
participated to some degree in this in
this
trade for two centuries the Dutch East
India Company dominates trade between
Asia and its headquarters in Amsterdam
making the city the key commercial
center in the
world the Dutch East India Company was
one of the very first large
multinational
corporations it's mission is
profit to trade silver for spices using
ships like the rosik to spearhead
trade an earlier commercial dive
uncovers the first evidence of the high
value of the
ship two
chests cracked open there's a sight
straight out of a high seas adventure
story in each 50 bars of silver bullion
blackened by the water worth of Fortune
and now divided between the Salvage team
and the Dutch
government but the smuggled coins add
new understanding to one of the most
colorful sagas in the age of Discovery
and reveal that everyone is secretly in
on the
tank it's estimated that 50% of all the
silver on board was smuggled bunny so if
you think about the rosik 36,000 coins
on board officially so that means 36,000
coins on board
unofficially that's an amazing amount of
money how much more is there to
[Music]
find it's 6 weeks into the 12we
Expedition at a Harborside lab experts
carefully record the archaeological
Treasures so they can be studied
anywhere in the world World in stunning
3D
detail comper table
wear glass bottles from the Captain's
Table and more company
coins we've only found 700 so far there
are many thousand more to
find with only a few weeks left on the
project the race is on to recover as
much as possible
and the team now also wants to solve the
rose vik's long-standing
mystery how exactly did it meet its
fate the drained wreckage of the ship
reveals
Clues the stern section can be seen
lying in a
pile more than 300 ft away
there's an
anchor and farther out several Cannon
grouped
together what does this spread of Clues
reveal this is the evidence of the
people struggling and trying to save
their
ship the ship was caught by the storm
was pushed on the sandbanks of the
Goodwin sense it's just been smashed on
the
Sands so what do you do you throw away
your heavy
equipment and you start with your
cannons during the storm the crew
ditches at least 23 cannon in an attempt
to lighten the ship and break free from
the
sandbanks then the crew drops
anchor but there's no chance of Escape
it just gets stuck further and
further the sea lifting the ship and
just pounding it onto the sand breaking
it in in thousands of
pieces and everybody was
lost it's almost
unimaginable the loss of the Ros viik
silver is a big blow for the Dutch East
India
Company shipwrecks are one of the the
recurring threats for for the company so
yearly there would be losses of ships
one or two on
average and some historians see this is
is one of the factors that contributes
to the demise of the Dutch East India
Company now after 12 weeks of
challenging
excavation the archaeological Expedition
is almost at an end so this is the last
night of the project 12 weeks of a great
dice but also um uh we had uh storms we
had lots of difficult Tides bad
visibility but uh We've also made a lot
of
progress we found around 2,000
coins both divers if you stop
work it's only a fraction of the coins
known to be on board including the
smuggled ones the value of Ros viik
silver could now be up to
$125
million Martin plans to return to the
rexite how much more of the rosev Sunken
Treasures can be recovered from the
shifting Sands
below archae ol ologists and treasure
Hunters continue to scour the
Seas and as the world's oceans continue
to drain away they reveal yet more
tantalizing clues of Fortunes lost under
the
waves the Florida
Keys in 1622 a Spanish gallion sinks
here Laden with an extraordinary Hall of
silver gold and
gems for decades treasure Hunters pursue
a
dream to find one of the richest wrecks
in
history can draining the oceans here
reveal the fabled motherload of the
vanished treasure ship at
[Music]
TOA I'm Kim fiser and I'm a treasure
hunter
Gold Fever treasure fever I think
everybody at some point in their life
has dreamed about finding
treasure off the coast of Key West
Florida a team of self-styled treasure
Hunters is chasing the legend of the
treasure ship Atocha known to have been
lost in these Waters nice clean bottom
looks like we got something coming in
here nice
Target once treasure and treasure ding
gets in your blood it's hard to get it
[Music]
out Maritime archaeologist Corey Malcolm
has spent two decades investigating the
fate of the Spanish
gallion the Atocha we know uh
specifically carried 260 people on
board some of these people were the
wealthiest people in the world you had
religious figures you had
explorers September 4th
1622 the nestra seora de Atocha is part
of a fleet of 28 ships that leaves
Havana Cuba Bound for
Spain it's Laden with silver gold and
gems more than a Year's worth of
treasure obtained by the Spanish from
their empire in Mexico and South America
the Atocha was a tremendously important
ship to Spain it was was carrying a huge
amount of treasure and there was over 30
tons of silver ingots on board 200,000
coins gold uh uh
emeralds but the Atocha quickly runs
into
trouble it wasn't a day out from Havana
that they started
feeling the wind
increase the Seas starting to build and
they knew they were
caught a hurricane closes
in the ship is
lost only five men survive to tell the
tale and their testimonies say that what
sunk the ship wasn't just the high wind
and waves there is clearly something
else here that poses a deadly threat to
shipping this this area is notorious for
shipwrecks Around a thousand ships have
been doomed along the Florida
Keys ships are drawn to these Waters to
make use of the Gulf Stream the ancient
Highway of the
[Music]
Seas the best way to see what might have
wrecked the Spanish Gall is to drain the
ocean now multi beam sonar scanning
details the extraordinary subsea
landscape around the Florida
Keys as the waters drain away a vast
Coastal mountain range is
revealed the shallow Florida Keys are
just the
Peaks Beyond them the land drops down up
to 6,000 ft into an ocean
Abyss this is the edge of the North
American continental
shelf we have a pretty dramatic drop off
here it goes down like a
wall further in from the Leading Edge an
amazing sight is now revealed hard
rock-like
formations this is North America's only
coral reef known as the Florida Reef
tract and it lies just under the surface
of the sea
today lighthouses stand guard here but
for the Spanish Traders on the Atocha
there is no such
warning a a ship like a Spanish gallion
that might draw 12 ft it uh is going to
hit a shallow Reef like that and and
it's going to have its bottom torn out
and
sink but will draining the Florida Keys
reveal the Atocha and its
treasure throughout the 1970s treasure
hunter Mel Fisher searches for the Lost
ship he and his family are driven by
stories of the legendary
treasure my dad was an eternal
Optimus today is the day he told us
every day today's the day we're going to
find
it for more than a decade the Fisher
team finds clues of the Atocha
Cannon and even silver
coins these fines are tantalizing and
help Finance the continuing search for
what the team calls the mother
l in the early years you know people
thought Mel was crazy oh it's you know
you're never going to find
it for some observers treasure hunting
and archaeological Pres obervation don't
mix Mel Fisher invented a propeller
blast system to clear away
sand recovering Sunken Treasures this
way can damage the seafloor and some of
the artifacts that lie upon
it but the treasure Hunters believe that
their work also helps us understand the
past we're kind of saving history you
know if we didn't go out there and
recover these items in a responsible
manner and bring them to light for the
public they would be lost
forever 15 years after the Fisher team
begins searching there's a
breakthrough cameras capture murky
images on the
seafloor draining away the Waters of the
Florida Keys reveals clearly one of the
most valuable shipwrecks in
history based upon the latest scanning
data and computer VIs visualization
technology it's possible to empty the
Seas exposing what the Fisher family
spent almost two decades looking
for Visible for the first time in four
centuries wreckage of the
Atocha 55 ft down once again open to the
light of
day strewn around Timbers from the
ship's Hall
Stones carried as ships
ballast poking out of the
mud debris of shattered treasure
chests it really doesn't look like a
ship anymore it's broken up it's
decayed among the wreckage a pile of
blackened
metal it's a massive block of silver
bars 30 tons in
total the motherload of the Atocha
exposed for all to
see it's an
emotion it was a wonderful feeling of
accomplishment to see Mel Fisher's dream
the motherload around the whole
bit when I got out of the water I went
over to my chart and I put a real X on
the chart of here's the
treasure it was totally
overwhelming we were all elated you know
we spent most of my life looking for
this one wreck now there it
was it's arguably the biggest ever Hall
of Spanish treasure making the Fisher
family and their backers wealthy beyond
their wildest dreams the mother load in
1985 was valued at about $400
million at that time between now and
then we've recovered a lot more and the
value in today's numbers you know it's
somewhere probably twice that you know
approaching a billion doll wreck it's
kind of
[Music]
mindboggling among the treasures are an
emerald and gold cross and
ring rare silver from the inin
Empire gold
chains and
cups and the fissures are not finished
yet their search for more of the Atocha
riches
continues based on what we see on the
Manifest and what's been recovered we
can estimate there's 300 silver
bars there was about 70 lbs of emeralds
smuggled on board the Atocha and we've
only found about 6 or seven lounds so
far there's still a lot of treasure out
there to be
found the Fisher team has discovered
that treasure from the Atocha has been
found not just at the mother but spread
out over
miles why is it spread so widely and can
draining the trail of wreckage lead to
finding a second
motherland
yeah keep your eye on that forward sonar
just let me know if you see any
Targets the hunt for the Atocha lost
emeralds is now focused on a missing
part of the
ship the stern castle where the
wealthiest people on board have their
cabins my number one target is probably
a pile of
emeralds emeralds are so
valuable that you could have one box
full of emeralds that would be worth a
whole ship full of
silver the mus produces the best
emeralds in the world even
today so keep your eyes open for big
emeralds that's that's the big
prize critical Clues lie in the spread
of wreckage and previously discovered
Treasures the treasure Hunters call it
the Atocha Trail
depth is good there's a Target coming in
right there might be something we have
to go
dig with the Waters of the Florida Keys
drained
away the true extent of the Atocha Trail
is
revealed survivors accounts report that
the ship hits the outer Reef
here and eventually sinks 2 miles away
at the site where the motherload is
found but then the trail of wreckage
appears to continue on for miles each
point here marks a treasure already
discovered but creates almost a a
breadcrumb trail on the sea
floor why are the Atocha Treasures
spread over 10 miles of
seabed following the trail itself gives
the treasure Hunters the answer we piece
together what
happened after the hurricane sinks the
Atocha in September of
1622 another great storm pounds the
sunken
record 30 days after the Atocha sank the
second hurricane
came the bow and the stern in the upper
decks all ripped loose in that second
storm and started bouncing along leaving
a tra of treasure lying 4 miles from the
motherload is what's thought to be the
bow section of the ship but the trail
appears to continue even
further that superr structure carried
off breaking up as it went along and and
dropping things the missing Stern castle
and a huge amount of treasure is
projected to lie somewhere in this
area
and now new technology a hovering
autonomous underwater vehicle or hauv
allows the treasure Hunters to find the
tiniest
Clues it lets us scan large areas of
seaf
Flor working under a legal permit the
new equipment will use a highfrequency
magnetic field
detector so we can detect Metals deeper
than ever before
and we can start to discriminate
different metals and where there's more
metal the Fisher team expects to find
the missing part of the ship and lost
emeralds looks like we got something
coming in right here that's just a
matter of systematically working the
trail of known artifacts and kind of
like breadcrumbs through the
forest the search
continues
[Music]
the age of the Spanish gallions is what
many consider the first golden age of
treasure on the high
seas but across the world's oceans the
amount of gold moved in the 20th century
especially during World War II dwarfs
all other
periods as the oceans of the world drain
away an extraordinary wreck is revealed
near the Arctic
Circle can draining a sunken British
warship uncover the fate of the world's
largest ever Hall of gold
bullion the Arctic
Ocean 200 mil off the coast of Russia
somewhere beneath these freezing Waters
lies one of the greatest secrets of
World War
II as the o ocean begins to empty it
reveals an astonishing
sight the 600t long wreck of HMS
Edinburg visible in its entirety for the
first time in more than 70
years the British warship guns can be
seen in the clear light of
day on the stern the quarter deck is
peeled
back
there's clear evidence of torpedo damage
a huge hole in the
side but a German torpedo didn't sink
the
Edinburg so what did and
why April 30th
1942 the barren sea in the Arctic
Circle it's the height of World War II
and a convoy of 13 British ships is on a
parall 1700 mile Voyage from Russia to
their allies in the
west it's one of the hardest campaigns
of the war you were under very serious
attack from submarines from
aircraft and even from surface
ships escorting the Convoy is the 600t
long 10,000 ton Cruiser HMS
Edinburgh it's a formidable warship with
with more than 24
guns a German ubo attacks the Germans
carried out a torpedo
attack another torpedo hit the ship
increasing the
damage 60 people are
killed 2 Days Later the remaining crew
are ordered to abandon ship forcing a a
fateful decision on the Navy the Admiral
decided that it was too far gone and he
ordered one of the Destroyers to put a
torpedo into her engine
room she went down within a couple of
minutes and she went completely
vertical HMS Edinburg sinks beneath the
waves 200 miles off the coast of Russia
sunk by its own
Navy it was vitally
important you didn't want her falling
into German hands but why take such
Extreme Measures to keep the Edinburg
out of Nazi
hands the answer is gold the gold that
was loaded on board the Edinburgh mank
was we know for certain was 5 and 1/2
tons that's what the Admiral signed for
and 5 and2 tons was
bars its payment from Russia for war
supplies and worth $240 million in
today's
money in 1942 recovering the gold from
the damaged ship just before it sinks is
too
dangerous the sunken treasure lies
undisturbed for decades and the ship is
recognized as a war
grave but then a dive Expedition San by
the British and Russian governments is
launched to salvage it leading the Hunt
is treasure diver Keith Jessup working
with Marine engineer Rick
Wharton what drove us to it is
interesting there was the of gold but
frankly we didn't have great
expectations at that stage of that there
were so many unknowns like a
moonshot the Edinburg is 800 ft beneath
the waves in freezing Waters and there's
no guarantee of success the first
challenge is finding a precise spot to
search it's suspected that the gold is
stored in the bomb
room the problem is this is one of the
most secure areas on the
ship situated deep inside the hle the
bomb room is where explosives are kept
and valuable cargo
and it's behind the ship's 4-in armor
plating will draining the Arctic Ocean
reveal how to access the wreck of HMS
Edinburg to recover its
treasures at 800 ft down the wreck of
HMS Edinburg is too deep for scuba
divers to stand any chance of success it
will take a remarkable feat of human
endurance the team needs to operate in a
Hightech pressurized chamber that looks
like something found on a space
station it's a technique called
saturation
diving you basically go into a chamber
and you're diving your body is saturated
with diving gases and you remain
saturated for the duration of the
dive saturating the diver's body with a
mix of diving gases avoids long and
costly decompression
times leaving the chamber the divers
enter a diving bell which drops through
a hole in the ship and enters the
freezing Arctic
Waters they leave the diving bell but
remain attached by an umbilical
cord the biggest problem I think we had
diving a depth on the Edinburgh was
staying
warm we had hot water suits and we had
had hot water been pumped down through
from the
surface too hot and the divers could be
badly scalded or if the supply fails
they could find themselves at the mercy
of the freezing cold Arctic
[Music]
Waters then we'd be breathing a very hot
gas which was starting to burn the
lungs it was like being kicked in the
back of the head by mule it wasn't
pleasant
ding the plan is for the divers to enter
the ship through the torpedo hole in the
side then work their way through the
ship to the bomb room but during the
first
dive there's an unexpected
problem when they got into that hole it
was completely we couldn't get the
debris out it's a setback and the team
is forced to rethink the B was ringed
with armor plating and we would have
struggled to to get through that so we
decided to go underneath the B plating
and cut our way into the
ship cutting into the bomb room is
fraught with
danger it may still contain unstable
explosive charges left over from the
war we knew the inherent dangers we knew
the risks and we were very slow and
cautious when we were cutting our way
into something I actually cut my way
into the bomb room
first there's no visibility you couldn't
see anything you couldn't see your hand
in front of your face everything was
feel and then uh I touched something
that was slightly heavy I tried to pick
it up and because of its size it should
have been easily be able to lift it but
the weight straight away gave me some
sort of idea that this wasn't something
ordinary as soon as I lifted it I knew
straight away that it was
gold you don't see that often at 800 ft
Roger
Roger I don't know about you job but I'm
shaking like
hell and then Euphoria broke out on the
boat as well everybody's running around
shouting and screaming and carrying on
from the crew down so it was a very
exciting
moment in total 460 bars of gold are
recovered worth about
$240 million in today's
money it's the biggest of lost gold
bullion ever recovered from the
seabed this is a lead copy gold plated
there's a a serial number at the top
which is
kp62 below that you see the hammer and
sickle and the Russian markings in a
cartouch below that it said
99.99 that's pure
gold the value of the treasure is shared
between the Russian and British
governments and the Salvage
team it was a vast amount of money we
all did very well out of it it
completely changed our attitude to work
because we never really had to again we
did of
course now emptied of its sunken
treasure peace returns to the
edur gold is always captur people's
imagination yeah it's treasure fever
there's millions of shipwrecks out
there but for every 10,000 shipwrecks on
the seab B prob one might be high
value once you start once you go look
for one you can never
[Music]
stop